Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu UKW, unsere kleine Welt.
Mein Name ist Tim Prittlaff und das hier ist die 118. Ausgabe von UKW.
Und nach einer etwas ausführlicheren Winterpause möchte ich das Thema Ukraine wieder aufgreifen.
Und ausnahmsweise heute mal nicht mit Pavel, sondern ich begrüße nach viel zu
langer Zeit mal den Enno wieder im Studio. Hallo Enno.
Hallo Tim.
Enno, Enno Lenze, wir hatten zuletzt im April 2022, also kurz nach Ausbruch
des Krieges, miteinander gesprochen.
Gerade jetzt hier im Vorfeld waren wir beide so ein bisschen überrascht,
dass wir eigentlich dazwischen gar nichts aufgenommen hatten.
Ich habe da ein paar Mal drüber nachgedacht, weil du bist ja viel gereist in die Ukraine.
Letztes Mal hatten wir darüber gesprochen, da warst du ja zufällig gleich nach
dem Vorfall in Butscha, genau dort bist du ja quasi vorbeigekommen,
da hast du uns diese Eindrücke geschildert.
Das heißt, was wir uns zuletzt angeschaut haben, war quasi die Situation unmittelbar
nach Kriegsausbruch, die ja glaube ich mit der heutigen Situation so überhaupt
nicht mehr zu vergleichen ist.
Damals stand halt Russland literally vor den Toren der Hauptstadt.
Das ist alles, wie wir hier auch verfolgt haben.
Mittlerweile, ja, Geschichte ist vielleicht ein bisschen ein großes Wort,
aber zumindest so nähere Vergangenheit, das hat sich auf jeden Fall geändert.
Tatsächlich blicken wir jetzt eher auf ein Jahr nicht nennenswert verschobener Fronten zurück.
Und naja, man hat also jetzt eine Ukraine, die so zum Teil befriedet ist,
Weil die Russen dort nie hingekommen sind und natürlich den Teil,
der heftig umkämpft ist.
Und ich wollte deswegen heute mal auf deine zwischenzeitlichen Erfahrungen schauen
und generell mal quasi diese Beobachtung des Krieges als solches in den Fokus nehmen.
Wie oft warst du denn seitdem, seit diesem Besuch in Butscha und Kiew wieder in der Ukraine?
Ich habe gerade nachgeguckt, 13 Mal müsste ich da gewesen sein.
Ich habe so drei Seiten im Pass Ein- und Ausreisestempel Ukraine.
Die setzen die schön aneinander und machen das platzsparend und es wird trotzdem voll.
Und das heißt, du warst auch sehr regelmäßig da.
Also im Prinzip ohne längere Pausen, alle ein bis zwei Monate so.
Tja, beneidenswert irgendwie. Was hast du, welche Bereiche, also welche Gegenden hast du da bereist?
Ich glaube, relativ alles im Osten, was relevant war.
Also Kiew, dann im Norden davon Tschernihiv, das ist so Richtung Belarus.
Dann ganz im Osten Charkiv, das ist so die letzte Großstadt,
bevor dann Russland kommt.
Von da nach Süden runter Isium, kleiner Ort.
Und dann Kramatorsk, das ist so die nächste Stadt neben der dann Bachmut kommt.
Dann weiter runter Prokofsk, so ein kleines Dorf oder ein kleiner Ort,
der so vor ein paar Wochen durch die Medien ging, weil da das Drushba Hotel bombardiert wurde.
Dann Saporica, wo quasi schräg gegenüber das vermiente Atomkraftwerk Enahoda
ist und dann so weiter nach Mikolaev,
da war ich als Rehazorn noch nicht befreit, weil es Mikolaev so die letzte Stadt
war und sozusagen dann zurück nach Lviv,
um sozusagen einmal die Runde zu schließen.
Also so halbwegs alle größeren relevanten Gegenden.
Und wie einfach ist es denn gewesen, in das Land zu kommen?
Sagen wir mal, Rhein ist wirklich so trivial wie vorher.
Das einzige Problem ist, die Flüge gibt es halt nicht, wegen der Flugabwehr.
Aber man kann Zug fahren, man kann Auto fahren.
Man kann quasi, als wir letztes Mal hier gesprochen haben, April 2022,
fing Flixbus wieder an, nonstop Berlin-Kiew zu fahren für 39 Euro.
Also das ist so die Messlatte für, man kommt einfach hin, wenn man 26 Stunden im Bus sitzen kann.
Auch die Grenze und so ganz praktisch das ist super trivial,
das ist nicht anders als in anderen Ländern und in der Ukraine selber,
Kann man sich an sich frei bewegen, ohne dass irgendjemand fragt, was man da treibt.
Eben nur, wenn es wirklich in die, sagen wir mal Front, also Front,
je nach Sichtweise anders.
Sagen wir mal, wenn man so 40, 50 Kilometer an die Russen rankommt ungefähr,
da kann es sein, dass es dann heißt, Moment, du darfst hier nur durch,
wenn du einen Grund nachweisen kannst.
Also wenn du hier wohnst oder jemanden besuchst oder in meinem Fall als Journalist.
Und dann kann man aber auch einfach weiterfahren. Also da wird man nur gestoppt
und sie sagen, was treibst du hier? Dann sagt man, ich will da vorne gucken. Okay.
Aber es ist wirklich extrem einfach.
Und wen trifft man dann so an, wenn man in dieses Land gefahren ist?
Also ist man dann auf einmal nur noch umgeben von Ukrainern oder ist es irgendwie
vielleicht dann doch etwas internationaler, als man sich das jetzt vielleicht so vorstellt?
Ich würde sagen in erster Linie wirklich Ukrainer. Also die sozusagen sie dominieren
das Straßenbild nach wie vor.
Also es ist jetzt nicht, dass man das Gefühl hat, man kommt in so ein UN-Flüchtlingscamp
oder irgendwas, sondern es ist wirklich ganz normales Leben.
Also die Touristen fehlen, das ist nicht wie Berlin.
Ist aber auch nicht wie Irak, als der islamische Staat da war,
was so militär dominiert war, sondern es ist wirklich wie Alltag erstmal.
Und wenn man dann in bestimmte Hotels oder bestimmte Restaurants geht,
sieht man halt die verschiedenen NGOs, also die, die sozusagen vom Restaurant aus arbeiten.
Und wenn man dann an die Front geht, ist es aber immer noch so,
dass es fast nur Ukrainer sind und man trifft wirklich selten auf ausländische
NGOs oder Medien, obwohl Unmengen im Land sind.
Das Land ist groß, also dass man sich wirklich trifft, ist überraschend selten,
wenn man sich nicht verabredet hat.
Deckt sich das so mit deinen Erfahrungen aus anderen Konfliktgebieten oder ist da irgendwas anders?
Ich glaube, der Hauptunterschied ist, zum Beispiel als die in Kurdistan gegen
den islamischen Staat gekämpft haben, kamen ja Unmengen Flüchtlinge in das Land
oder also in die Gegend von Kurdistan aus den anderen Gebieten.
Und da gab es halt überall Flüchtlingscamps für die und die mussten versorgt
werden. Das war dadurch sehr auffällig, dass die halt überall waren.
Und das ist in der Ukraine eben nicht, da flüchtet keiner hin.
Zum Beispiel in Afghanistan, als ich da war, nachdem die Taliban übernommen
hatten, da haben sich in erster Linie die NGOs auf ein paar Gegenden getummelt.
Das war auch anders vom Erscheinungsbild. Also sozusagen unter Taliban-Kontrolle
merkte man, die kontrollieren alles, also wie so ein Polizeistaat mit überall Kontrollen.
In Kurdistan, Irak waren halt Flüchtlinge und die Versorgung so dominant.
Und in der Ukraine hat man jetzt erstmal das Gefühl, wenn man ankommt,
dass es, also in den großen Städten wie Kiew oder Lviv, dass es ganz normaler Alltag ist.
Aber nicht, dass der Krieg im Vordergrund steht oder irgendein Aspekt des Krieges.
Das gibt es dann in ein paar Ecken. Aber jetzt, wenn man normal am Bahnhof ankommt,
in sein Hotel fährt, kann es gut sein, dass man gar nichts vom Krieg wahrnimmt.
Mhm.
Ich denke mal, das dürfte ja dann auch sehr gestaffelt sein,
je nachdem, wo man jetzt ist.
Du hast Lviv erwähnt, das ist ja im Prinzip die größte Stadt,
oder die dem Westen nächste Großstadt. Ja.
Genau, eine Stunde von der Grenze direkt, ja. So.
Und wenn ich das richtig mitbekommen habe,
ist das ja auch so ein Primärkontaktpunkt mit dem Westen, auch jetzt so auf
militärischer Basis, dort sind glaube ich Stellen gewesen,
weiß ja nicht wie das jetzt ist, wo so freiwillige Soldaten aus dem Westen auch
zuerst aufgeschlagen sind.
Es gab da glaube ich mal einen Raketenangriff auf so ein Zentrum.
Kann man sich das dann so vorstellen, dass Lviv gerade so ein bisschen der internationalste
Kontaktpunkt ist oder ist das dann doch eher die Hauptstadt?
Sag mal, Lviv war es am Anfang, also als Kiew noch unter, also sozusagen halb
umstellt war von Russen.
Da war Lviv echt der Dreh- und Angelpunkt für alles.
Da gab es auch so wirklich die Bilder, du bist zu einem Hotel gekommen und davor
haben sich so dermaßen Autos von NGOs und Nachrichtenagenturen gestapelt,
dass rechts und links die Bürgersteige voll standen. Also wenn man ankam und
sagt, okay, hier ist voll.
Und auch tatsächlich so Sachen mit ein Starlink auf dem Bürgersteig mit so drei
Pylonen drum und ein Kabel durchs Fenster im zweiten Stock und sowas.
Also so Dinge, wo man sagt, also so improvisiert Nachrichten,
also wie man sich das vorstellt. Und das war aber auch schon vor fast zwei Jahren,
so im Mai 2022 war die Phase aber auch schon vorbei irgendwie.
Das war nur ganz kurz und danach waren die Hotels wieder fast normal besetzt
und es waren mehr in Kiew.
Aber mir schien, ein Teil war wieder nach Hause.
Und in Kiew hat es sich mehr verbreitet. Also in Kiew kann man eigentlich alle
treffen, alle Nachrichten, alle militärischen Leute, die da sind, auch aus dem Ausland.
Aber man läuft denen nicht zufällig über den Weg. Das ist das Komische.
Also wenn man so eine Liste machen würde, wer alles da ist, wäre die wahrscheinlich
ein halber Katalog lang.
Und wenn man jetzt aber einfach durch die Innenstadt läuft, trifft man nicht
zufällig auf einen, weil es halt trotzdem eine Millionenstadt ist.
Also das fand ich so komisch, weil man, also ich denke, da werden zehntausende
Leute aus dem Ausland sein in Kiew, die irgendwelche Sachen da machen.
Zum einen haben viele aber auch nichts an, woran man sie erkennt.
Also die wenigsten haben so, also jetzt in Kurdistan hatten sie meist ihre NGO-Jacken
an, weil sie in ihre Camps rein und raus mussten.
In Kiew gibt es gar keinen Grund dafür. Da kann man sich ganz normal kleiden.
Und ich glaube, deswegen ist das halt auch so vom Erscheinungsbild her halt
wirklich nichts, wo man das Gefühl hat, dass die Leute da präsent sind.
Aber wenn man zum Beispiel in bestimmte Hotels geht, die immer von den Journalisten
genutzt wurden, also es gibt eins, da gehe ich fast immer zum Abendessen hin
und es kommt immer irgendjemand Interessantes vorbei.
Bei. Oder es kommen auf einmal ganz viele schwerbewaffnete Soldaten rein und gucken sich um.
Dann weiß man, oh, gleich kommt jemand Spannendes. Mal gucken, wer es ist.
Und dann passiert so, dass sich der Außenminister irgendwie neben dir an den Tisch setzt.
Oder dass, wir hatten es einmal, dass Selenskyj irgendwen da begrüßt hat, so 20 Meter von uns.
Also da gibt es so ein paar Spots, wo man was geboten kriegt,
aber halt auch zufällig.
Und das finde ich das Das ist das Merkwürdige. Und wenn man dann auf Twitter
fragt, hey, wer ist in der Stadt, wen kann ich treffen, melden sich auf einmal
100 Leute und denkt, wo seid ihr denn?
Also ich sehe fast keinen, wenn ich nicht aktiv suche.
Und sobald man aber fragt, findet man sie alle.
Und ich nehme an, Twitter ist auch nach wie vor da der Kommunikationskanal, über den das läuft. Ja.
Also für mich in erster Linie Twitter. Also mir scheint, es kommt so ein bisschen
drauf an, aber ich meine, Twitter hat eine vernünftige Suche,
muss man sagen, im Vergleich zu Mastodon.
Instagram ist, finde ich, ja unbenutzbar als Community oder sowas.
Ein paar Leute haben mir gesagt, sie haben Kontakt über TikTok,
aber das ist auch immer so zufällig.
Es scheint wirklich, wenn man so einfach nur so einen Überblick haben will oder
also zum einen, wenn man sich einfach informieren will oder wenn man auf Masse was raushauen will,
da ist Twitter auf jeden Fall ganz vorne und dann auf Platz zwei sozusagen dafür
vorgesehene meist Telegram-Kanäle.
Also es gibt halt so welche Freelancer in der Ukraine, NGOs,
also sowieso wie früher die Villa, so der offene Chat, wo man vorbeikommt und
Interesse begründet, aber die Chats sind meist so ein Chaos.
Also das geht, aber es ist halt ein solches Grundrauschen, dass es anstrengend ist. Ja.
Ja, das ist so. Kommen wir vielleicht später auch nochmal ein bisschen drauf,
wie wir so mit unseren Quellen umgehen, wie sich das so entwickelt hat.
Aber bleiben wir vielleicht nochmal bei den Städten. Achso.
Ein Detail noch, weil mir gerade einfiel, was mache ich denn ganz praktisch, wenn ich ankomme?
Wenn man halt ein paar Leute kontaktiert hat, also wenn man dann erstmal so
im Laufe der Zeit Leute kennt, ist es halt meistens so, wenn ich rüberfahre,
schreibe ich per WhatsApp einfach die Leute an und sage, hey,
ich komme. Bist du in der Stadt? Bist du irgendwo?
Also sei es Militär, sei es andere Journalisten, sei es, es gibt so Leute,
die in der Ukraine sozusagen spenden, channeln und annehmen und dann weiter
verteilen, also wie so Hubs.
Und dann guckt man halt, wer da ist und danach entscheide ich dann auch auf
meine Reiseroute, dass ich sage, okay, dann fahre ich mal in der Stadt vorbei
oder einer sagt, ey, wir sind aber jetzt die Woche in Kharkiv,
dann sagt man, gut, dann komme ich vorbei,
gucken, was du da treibst und also so typisches Networken und das Netzwerk dann auswalzen.
Und dann aber auch immer mit dem Auto unterwegs.
Eigentlich ja. Also man kann in der Ukraine exzellent Zug fahren,
von überall nach überall in den großen Städten, aber ich muss halt oft dann
neben die große Stadt in ein Dorf oder so.
Inzwischen haben sogar wieder die Autovermietung auf, aber Schäden durch den
Krieg sind nicht versichert.
Und ich nehme halt immer noch meist ein gepanzertes Fahrzeug mit,
ist für 90% der Ukraine egal, aber für die letzten 10% fühlt man sich dann doch sicherer.
Mhm.
Ja, dann wäre sozusagen die nächste Stadt, wo es ja dann auch gerade leider
jetzt im Winter wieder etwas ungemütlicher geworden ist, wäre Kharkiv.
Eine Stadt, die ja auch ganz zu Beginn extrem bedroht war, eingenommen zu werden.
Das konnte ja zurückgeschlagen werden, dann war es längere Zeit ziemlich ruhig,
insbesondere nachdem halt in der Kharkiv-Region diese Gegenoffensive so erfolgreich war.
Aber jetzt ist halt Rakiv ein beliebtes Ziel der Mittelstreckenraketen der Russen geworden.
Es liegt halt sehr nah an der Grenze und ist von daher sehr schwierig auch zu verteidigen.
Also man braucht dann eben auch jeweils für die jeweilige Raketenkonstruktion
eben auch das passende Verteidigungssystem.
Da ist es jetzt wahrscheinlich ein bisschen ungemütlicher, oder?
Ja, wobei, nachdem wir letztes Mal gesprochen haben, ich weiß gar nicht mehr,
ein oder zwei Wochen später war ich in Charkiv, als es da echt noch Wüst war.
Also wo man noch beim Laufen durch die Stadt die ganze Zeit,
den ganzen Tag die Artillerie in der Ferne gehört hat.
Und das war, also das war richtig gruselig. Da waren wir auch da,
als diese S-300-Raketen eingeschlagen sind und so. Das ist ziemlich heftig.
Und inzwischen ist es so, dass im Alltag, dass da alles auch wieder relativ normal ist.
Aber im Vergleich zu Kiew sieht man in Kharkiv eine Menge Zerstörung.
Also wenn man einfach, wenn man heute durch Kiew mit dem Auto fährt,
man muss echt suchen nach den Gebäuden, wo was kaputt gegangen ist.
Und in Kharkiv sieht man eine Menge, gerade in der Innenstadt,
also die, die wirklich richtig kaputt und ausgebombt sind. Das ist so der eine Punkt.
Und wie du sagst, es ist dicht an der Grenze. Was ich da auch ganz interessant fand,
wenn man von Polen in die Ukraine fährt, sozusagen in Polen bis ans Ende der
Autobahn und dann über den Hauptübergabe, über den Hauptgrenzpunkt,
dann hat man auf der ukrainischen Seite eine Landstraße mit einer Spur pro Richtung
nach Lviv und die ist so im mittelmäßigen Zustand.
Also da ist nicht mal eine Autobahn sozusagen von Lviv nach Westen.
Und wenn man von Kiew nach Kharkiv fährt, hat man eine ordentliche Autobahn
und von Kharkiv Richtung Russland.
Also das ist nur so sinnbildlich für, wie das Land doch halt sehr Russland ausgelegt
oder angebunden oder wie man es nennen will, lange war.
Also ja wirtschaftlich und ich meine auch von der Sprache und allem was näher.
Aber da wird einem das so klar, wenn man da sozusagen die Autobahn Richtung
Osten fährt und Richtung Westen die Straßen immer kleiner werden.
Das fand ich nur ganz interessant, weil es einem dann so richtig auffällt.
Jetzt im, ich war halt Weihnachten in Charkiv und ich war im Charkiv Palace
Hotel, weil ich da ein paar Mal war und das ist dann auch, ich glaube,
zwei Tage später bombardiert worden.
Ähm, das ist dann halt auch, also, dass da Sachen bombardiert werden, ist die eine Sache.
Aber wenn man, also ich war häufig in dem Hotel und kenne ein paar Leute vom
Personal und wir haben getratscht und sich verabschiedet und dann liest man
auf einmal, da ist eine Rakete eingeschlagen, das ist halt auch nochmal eine
ganze Nummer anders. Und die dann auch erstmal angeschrieben, ob sie okay sind.
Und die waren gut vorbereitet, dass irgendwas passieren kann und deswegen gab
es auch keine, also soweit ich weiß, keine Toten und keine schlimmen Verletzten.
Und sie haben das in Rekordzeit evakuiert. Also man merkte, die waren gut im
Training, falls was passiert, dass sie alle sich herausbringen.
Aber da hat man wieder gemerkt, ja, Kharkiv, auch wenn es so im Alltag echt,
man gewöhnt sich dran, da haben die teuren Restaurants wieder auf,
der Freizeitpark hat teilweise auf und solche Sachen.
Und dann schlägt aber eine Rakete mitten in der Stadt wieder ein.
Also da ist der Krieg noch deutlich näher als in Kiew.
Also es ist so komisch, aber wenn man in Kiew ist und es schlägt im anderen
Stadtteil eine Drohne ein, dann hört man das oft nicht mal.
Das kriegt man nicht mit, man liest es halt nur. Nur, wenn man in Charkiv ist,
weil es auch kleiner ist, dann kommt so eine ballistische Rakete runter, da wackelt die Bude.
Also so da weiß man, da ist was eingeschlagen.
Das ist so, das macht dann doch einen ganz deutlichen Unterschied in der Wahrnehmung.
Wie ist denn das, wenn so eine Bombe in der Nähe explodiert?
Also wie oft hast du das gehabt so und wie nah war das an dir dran?
Ich glaube zehnmal oder so inzwischen. Auch letztes Mal ist über uns eine Shahed
abgeschossen worden, also wirklich über unserem Auto beim Fahren.
Das war auch ein bisschen gruselig.
Shaheds sind diese motorübschriebenen iranischen Drohnen, die ein großes Problem darstellen.
Genau, die sind relativ groß. Die haben so drei, vier Meter Spannweite, glaube ich.
Also wenn man die so isoliert auf dem Foto sieht, finde ich,
sieht man immer nicht, wie groß die sind.
Aber die sind schon, also die machen schon was her.
Naja, die passen nicht in den Fahrstuhl.
Ne genau, also die kann man auch nicht wie so ein ferngesteuertes Flugzeug aus
der Hand starten, die sind schon wie ein Mini-Flugzeug.
Genau, also wir hatten das einmal in Charkiv, das war gleich das erste Mal,
dass wir so richtig fette Einschläge hatten.
Das war so komisch, ich bin aufgewacht, weil es einen unglaublichen Knall gab.
Also ich meine, man kennt ja so Silvesterböller und man kennt die in Berlin
auch, wenn sie dicht an einem explodieren oder selten, wenn mal irgendwie ein
Fahrradreifen oder so platzt.
Und da hat man den Knall, aber in dem Sinne keine Druckwelle oder nicht,
wie so ein Erdbeben oder so.
Und ich bin halt wach geworden, weil es unglaublich geknallt hat und wirklich
das ganze Gebäude gewackelt hat und in meiner Minibar die Flaschen aneinander
gekleert haben, also wie so ein Erdbeben.
Und ich habe mich dann aus dem Bett gerollt. Also auch so, man lernt ja so eine
Menge dämlichen Kram, denkt man erst, der aber praktisch ist,
dass man immer so schläft,
dass man auf der gleichen Seite das Fenster nach draußen hat und auf der gleichen
Seite die sichere Seite.
Das heißt, ich schlafe immer so, dass ich auf meiner rechten Seite,
egal wie rum das Bett steht, meine sichere Seite habe.
Und wenn ich dann nachts so einen Knall höre, da wo keine Fenster sind.
Weil Fenster, wenn es eine Explosion gibt, splittern.
Und die Splitter machen Schnittverletzungen und Schnittverletzungen heißen, dein Blutdruck sinkt.
Das heißt, manchmal schläft man dann im Hotel sozusagen mit den Füßen am Kopfende,
wenn man so will, dass man aber nicht drüber nachdenken muss, wo was ist.
Und als diese Explosion kam, habe ich mich halt rechts aus dem Bett gerollt.
Dann weiß ich, ich bin erstmal zwischen mir und der Scheibe ist noch ein Bett,
wenn jetzt noch was explodiert.
Und bin dann, da liegen dann halt schlusslich Reveste und Helm,
das halt so halb übergezogen und dann erstmal auf den Flur vom Hotel gekrabbelt.
Weil es da keine Scheiben gibt das ist so die erste Gefahr, die man hat,
halt diese Splitter und die Scheiben hatten aber wohl gehalten also war so dicht nicht dran,
und kamen halt auf den Flur gekrabbelt und da waren schon ein paar andere und der eine sagte,
krass, das war genau am Ende als der Alarm aufhörte also in dem Moment,
wo die Sirene das letzte Mal geheult hat das habe ich irgendwie verpennt,
die Sirene warum auch immer, also irgendwie so dran gewöhnt.
Und das war, wo ich dachte, okay, der war also knapp vorher wach,
ich bin beim Knall wach geworden und dann ging die Tür auf und jemand kam einfach
rausgelaufen, während wir da lagen und es sah so komisch aus, weil so die Füße kamen.
Der rieb sich so die Augen und sagt, könnt ihr auch nicht schlafen?
Ich sagte, was? Das stimmt mit dir nicht.
Und sagte, der ist irgendwie wach geworden und sagte, ja, es gab eine Explosion
und der andere sagte, nee, drei, drei und ich sagte, okay,
da dachte ich so verschieden sind die Wahrnehmungen von Leuten die quasi direkt daneben waren und dann,
kamen auch sofort welche vom Hotel die Etagen abgelaufen und sagten ja,
soweit sie wissen, drei ist 300,
und die waren so zwei Kilometer weg von uns und das heißt da sind wir nicht
mehr gefährdet in irgendeiner Art, soweit fliegt liegt auch kein Backstein oder
so, aber immer noch diese Vibration und dieser Knall mit so einer Intensität, das ist unglaublich.
Ja, und so ungenau, wie die S300 da eigentlich sind, hätte das also genauso
gut auch bei euch einschlagen können.
Genau.
Also ich habe gerade mal überlegt, ich war ja noch nie in einem Kriegsgebiet,
aber ich erinnere mich jetzt gerade, dass da, wo ich mal gewohnt habe, in Hannover, in der ...
In der Parallelstraße ist eine Gasexplosion gehabt.
Ja, das ist ähnlich von der Wucht her wahrscheinlich.
Genau, und dann hört man halt so richtig, wie die Fenster ächzen.
So dieses Knarzen, wenn wirklich die Scheibe so voll in die Fugen gedrückt wird.
Herr Kalloy, das muss das Boot abkönnen, so ein Geräusch. Das ging mir auch, dieses äh. Ja.
Und das ist da halt normal. Und dieser Fliegeralarm, wie oft geht der so los?
Wie laut ist das? Wenn du sagst, du bist jetzt mal nicht davon wach geworden
und der ist regelmäßig, dann wird man ja eigentlich jede Nacht wach.
Genau, das war auch so ein Hin und Her, wo wohl die Ukrainer überlegt haben.
Also zum einen, wo ich fasziniert war, sie haben eine Handy-App,
die funktioniert, eine Alarm-App und sie haben Sirenen.
Sie haben zwei Dinge, die wir nicht haben und die funktionieren.
Und die Sirenen sind wirklich, wie man das aus den Zweiten-Weltkrieg-Filmen
kennt oder zum Teil aus dem Stadion. Da wird das wohl manchmal noch benutzt,
diese Handsirenen, aber genau die Dinger. Ja, es ist unglaublich laut.
Also sind wirklich, eigentlich, normalerweise währt man von wach.
Und wenn es nicht zu kalt war, haben wir auch immer die Fenster zumindest auf Kipp gehabt.
Also wenn wir schlafen, damit wir das zum einen hören.
Und zum anderen, wenn wirklich eine Druckwelle kommt und das Fenster ganz geschlossen
ist, dann geht es eher kaputt, als wenn man es auf hat.
Oder man hat sozusagen die Verriegelung aufgemacht, das Fenster wieder zugedrückt,
dass wenn eine Druckwelle kommt, dass es auffliegen kann. So einfach,
um Splitter zu vermeiden.
Und das war teilweise sechs, sieben Mal am Tag.
Also und das Problem war dann, dass fast immer nichts passiert ist,
weil zum Beispiel, wenn bestimmte Kampfjets, also MiG-31K aufgestiegen sind
an der Grenze zur Ukraine,
also russische, dann wurde quasi in der ganzen Ukraine Alarm gegeben,
weil die so Raketen hatten, die in die ganze Ukraine schießen können.
Und vor einer Weile hat die Ukraine jetzt gesagt,
Sie machen diese allgemeinen Warnungen nicht mehr, weil es eben dazu führt,
dass die Leute es irgendwann nicht mehr ernst nehmen.
Wir auch nicht. Wir saßen im Café in Charkiv, also wo man so 90 Sekunden Anflugzeit
für eine Rakete hat und es gab Alarm und wir sind nicht mal mehr aus dem Café
gegangen, weil wir gesagt haben, es ist das vierte Mal heute,
ich habe gerade Kuchen bestellt.
Nee.
Echt nicht. Und es hat auch sonst keinen gestört. Also weil es so,
weil irgendwie man denkt, ja, weißt du, entweder, und wo willst du hinrennen?
Es gibt eh keinen Bunker. Du müsstest wissen, wo die nächste Tiefgarage oder Schutzraum ist.
Das ist halt auch so ein Punkt, wie du sagst, diese Raketen sind ungenau.
Die haben so plus minus einen Kilometer, glaube ich, als Einschlaggenauigkeit.
Und wenn die das Haus treffen, in dem du bist, geht das bis zum Keller weg.
Also ich habe Häuser gesehen, wo halt wirklich selbst der Keller kaputt war
und der Rest gefehlt hat.
Das ist Glücksache, ob du drinnen oder draußen sicherer bist.
Nur wenn du ein wirklich tiefes Parkhaus hast. Es gibt welche,
die haben so vier, fünf Etagen nach unten, da ist man sicher.
Oder die U-Bahn in Kiew.
Und dann wusste man, okay, jetzt ist Alarm. War auch krass, wenn man in so einem
Café war und auf einmal alle Handys so fast synchron anfangen,
dieses Alarmsignal zu machen.
Man merkt so, der Puls geht sofort hoch. Man ist so sofort angespannt.
Also so wie das so im Kopf festhängt dann. Und dann ...
Dann haben sie halt gesagt, okay, sie müssen irgendwie präziser warnen und die
Ansage in der App ist inzwischen so,
jetzt kommt der Alarm und dann kommt, geh wirklich jetzt in den Bunker oder
in den Schutzraum, weil so diese trügerische Sicherheit wird dich irgendwann umbringen.
Als Sprachansage. Genau, als Sprachansage.
Auf Ukrainisch dann.
Auf Englisch auch. Und bei der einen App hat ja der Luke Skywalker,
der Darsteller, die eingesprochen.
Der ist auch der Drohnen-Pate oder wie sich das nennt. Ich weiß nicht mehr ganz genau. ein.
Ja.
Genau, also der hat für eine App sozusagen die Stimme gegeben.
Wo ich aber auch denke, das ist geil, weil ich meine, so plump es ist,
am Ende musst du irgendwie die Leute drauf aufmerksam machen oder sie für das
Thema interessieren und das ist halt wieder ein Punkt, wo man sagt,
das ist aber irgendwie cool oder so, lass mal hinhören, ob ich die Stimme erkenne.
Der Mike Hamill ist auch eine coole Sau, also.
Ja und auch überhaupt sowas zu machen, Wo ich denke, das ist so geil und ja,
aber so sagen wir mal, ein paar Mal am Tag hat man das, wenn sozusagen eine heiße Phase ist, ja.
Aber ob man dann wirklich in Gefahr ist oder nicht, das ist im Prinzip ein Glücksspiel,
also sozusagen russisches Roulette mal wirklich. Ja, genau.
Genau.
Ja
Und das andere Wald, als wir Weihnachten dann von, ich glaube da waren wir noch
auf dem Weg nach Kiew, da sind wir halt, als es schon dunkel war,
auf der Autobahn gefahren. Ja.
Und aus dem, also wir sind mit mehreren Wagen gefahren und dann sagte einer,
hey, irgendwas ist da oben, irgendwas ist da oben rechts.
Keine Ahnung, kann sein, irgendwas wird irgendwo schon sein.
Dann sahen wir auf einmal von der einen Seite der Straße oder so ein Stück weiter
weg aber so diese Leuchtspurmunition, so diese roten Tracer durch die Luft fliegen, also über uns.
Und auf der anderen Seite von der Autobahn, wie was in der Luft explodierte
und so langsam runterkam. Sagt, okay.
Sagt, für ein Jet ist das definitiv zu klein.
Ich würde mal tippen, das war ein Gepard, der so eine Shahed-Drohne abgeschossen hat.
Könnte sein, genau. Und nachher haben wir dann, also man kann ja nachher,
ist ja sehr transparent, genau gucken, was wurde wie wo abgeschossen.
Da hieß es, da in genau der Ecke sind zwei Shahed abgeschossen worden.
Womit stand nicht, aber möglich, ja. Also auf jeden Fall irgendwas,
was Maschinengewehre drauf hatte.
Ab und zu schafft man es ja auch mit kleineren Maschinen, ganz selten vielleicht
mal mit einem Gewehr, aber der Gepard ist glaube ich schon so.
Der ist sehr zuverlässig, ja. Der kann das.
Also wenn so eine Shahed Drohne da in der Nähe ist, damit trifft man glaube
ich verhältnismäßig zuverlässig.
Man muss halt nur einen in der Nähe haben.
Ja genau, genau.
Okay, das heißt, jetzt sind wir so bis Kharkiv und das sind alles bedrohte Städte,
wo aber im Wesentlichen, so man davon überhaupt noch sprechen kann in der Ukraine,
das Leben mehr oder weniger versucht zumindest normal zu sein.
Jetzt hast du ja erwähnt, Kramatorsk, das ist ja eigentlich eine Frontstadt,
kann man sagen, weil der eigentliche Frontverlauf nicht weit weg ist.
Dort schlägt immer mal wieder was ein. Nein, zuletzt habe ich weniger darüber
gehört, aber man kriegt ja jetzt auch nicht jede Bombe mit.
Ist in der Nähe von Bachmut, das hast du ja auch schon gesagt.
Und wenn ich mich richtig entsinne, ist ja auch Kamatorsk so eigentlich das
militärische Widerstandszentrum in dieser Region.
Weil das ist ja jetzt auch kein neuer Frontverlauf, sondern das ist ja im Prinzip
der Frontverlauf, der schon seit 2014 existiert. und wo zuletzt quasi die Russen
erstmal auf Distanz gehalten wurden.
Ja und die waren ja in Kramatorsk 2014 oder 15, ich weiß nicht mehr, wann das genau war.
Da gab es die Schlacht um Kramatorsk, ich glaube sogar zwei, drei Wochen.
Das ist also ein bisschen, die einen sagen, das waren russische Soldaten und
die anderen sagen, nee, das waren Aufständischer. Ich meine am Ende irgendwie,
also irgendwelche russenaffinen Leute waren halt da.
Das war wirklich bis nach Kramatorsk rein. Nein, aber so wie so Straßenkämpfe
ein bisschen oder so, also nicht wie Fullscale War, aber deswegen waren die
da eh schon darauf vorbereitet, dass was passieren kann.
Dann diese Linie, die dann jetzt über Jahre sozusagen die Grenze war zwischen
Russisch und Ukrainisch.
Das ist so, ich glaube, 20 Kilometer oder sowas oder 30 weg.
Also nicht weit, sondern das ist halt die letzte Stadt wirklich in der Gegend.
Und dann kommt halt viel Kleinkram. Und da war ich auch im Dezember 2021 und
habe mit Leuten von der Special Monitoring Mission, von der OSZE gesprochen,
weil halt die Frage war, gibt es hier einen Krieg oder nicht?
Und ich dachte, die Leute, die wirklich vor Ort sind, also so am letzten Ort
und die jeden Tag damit zu tun haben, die haben meist einen sehr guten Einblick
oder die haben ein gutes Gefühl dafür.
Und die haben mir gesagt, auf gar keinen Fall greift Putin an.
Also so dämlich kann selbst der nicht sein.
Und das war für mich so der Grund, warum ich dachte, okay, wenn das selbst die
Fahrer und die Leute vor Ort von der Mission sagen und die,
die da wohnen, dann traue ich denen zu, dass sie sagen wir dass sie ein gutes
bild der lage haben und hatten sie dann offensichtlich auch nicht.
Ja, das ist so eine Schwierigkeit, das alles richtig einzuschätzen.
Ich glaube, da lagen so einige so ein bisschen daneben.
Wie ist das da in Kramatorsk? Also man ist ja immer ein bisschen überrascht,
also sogar so krass umkämpfte Städte kann man fast schon gar nicht mehr dazu sagen,
Orte wie jetzt Avdivka vor Donetsk, wo die Russen ja jetzt seit Monaten versuchen
da irgendwie mit einem unglaublichen Aufwand in irgendeiner Form Fortschritte
zu erzielen, die sie glücklicherweise nicht erzielen,
aber sogar dort leben ja noch teilweise noch Leute.
Also es ist immer wieder erschreckend, finde ich, aus meiner Perspektive zu
sehen, wie sehr die Gebiete, die jetzt konkret umkämpft sind,
teilweise noch bevölkert sind.
Und ich frage mich immer, warum sind da überhaupt noch welche?
Sind das einfach nur alte Leute, die es einfach nicht übers Herz bringen, ihren Ort zu verlassen?
Sind das mehr oder weniger Leute, die jede Hoffnung haben, eh fahren lassen
und sozusagen woanders für sich nichts mehr sehen oder die dort bleiben,
weil sie die Armee unterstützen wollen?
Was ist so ein bisschen deine Wahrnehmung?
Es gibt so zwei Hauptgruppen, habe ich das Gefühl.
Zum einen tatsächlich alte, die sagen, ich war hier irgendwie,
als die Nazis da waren, irgendwie als Baby noch und dann als die Sowjets kamen
und so weiter, ich bleibe immer hier.
Und zum anderen Leute zum Beispiel von Polizei und Rettungskräften und so weiter,
die also sozusagen ortsgebunden eh sind.
Aber eigentlich aus dem Ort stammen. Genau.
Also die von dort auch kommen, also die die vorm Krieg da gearbeitet haben und
die halt geblieben sind, weil sie sagen, ich kann hier nicht gehen.
Und dann eben oft die Familien von denen, also dass die dann auch sagen,
ich wollte die Kinder wegschicken, aber die wollen nicht.
Oder auch, dass sie keinen haben, wo die hin können, weil Oma und Opa sagen,
ich habe hier immer gelebt.
Die Eltern sagen irgendwie, ich bin bei der Polizei, ich kann hier nicht weg
und dann bleiben die Kinder halt auch. Auch.
Das ist so der typische Fall. Ganz, ganz selten, dass Leute,
dass ich die gesehen habe, die gesagt haben, sie bleiben aus Prinzip,
sondern fast immer eben, also ich meine Alte, die sagen, sie bleiben aus Prinzip,
aber junge Leute sind ganz oft dann zumindest zu Freunden, Verwandten oder so
ein Stück weiter, also irgendwie in die nächste sichere Stadt.
Und halt deswegen meist die, die sozusagen berufsbedingt in irgendeiner Form dort sind.
Zum Teil aber auch gerade in Kramatorsk so Sachen wie Kfz-Mechaniker oder so.
In Kramatorsk gab es eine Menge Autohäuser, weil es halt so für die Umgebung der große Ort war.
Die hatten auch immer Werkstätten.
Die hatten auch zwei große Werkstätten, die die gepanzerten Fahrzeuge von der OSZE gemacht haben.
Also die haben da zwei Werkstätten gehabt, die ich glaube 200 gepanzerte Autos
geservicet haben, die also grundsätzlich wissen, wieso diese spezielleren Stahlarten
und so zu behandeln sind.
Und es gab da auch einige Werkstätten.
Die haben so in den USA zu Schrott gefahrene Autos aufgekauft,
die dann quasi schiffsweise nach, ich glaube, in die Nähe von Moldawien oder
wo da der nächste größere Hafen ist, kommen.
Und dann zum Beispiel in die Ukraine gehen, weil die in den USA abgeschrieben
sind als Versicherungsschaden.
Also die dürfen da nicht mehr zugelassen werden, so ein bisschen auch Wirtschaftsförderung für die.
Und dann kommen die zum Beispiel in die Ukraine, werden wieder fit gemacht und
dann dort verkauft als reparierte Autos. und auch sowas war.
In Kramators gab es ein paar Anbieter, die genau das gemacht haben und die dann
wieder weiter ins restliche Land geschippt haben.
Das heißt, da gibt es aber einige Kompetenz, die man jetzt halt gerade gut brauchen kann.
Also Leute, die zum einen Fachwissen haben und zum anderen aber auch so fummeln
und tüddeln können, die hier in Deutschland immer so, ich finde,
fast so herablassend gesehen werden.
Also wenn du hier noch so einen hast, der irgendwie ein bisschen mit dem Lötkolben
umgehen kann. Und so genauso. Das ist so abfällig.
Und da auf einmal sind das jetzt die Leute, die du brauchst.
Oder der dicke Nerd, der Drohnen schraubt, über den du dich immer lustig machst,
das ist jetzt quasi der Kriegsheld in der Ukraine.
Nur deswegen gibt es in Kramatorsk sozusagen einiges an Infrastruktur,
was praktisch und nutzbar ist.
Da habe ich auch eins von den bizarren Bildern so geschossen.
Ich habe da, wir wussten nicht, wo man da parken kann, in der Nähe von einem
von den Autohäusern, was ich kannte, weil ich wollte gucken,
ob die noch da sind, was die machen.
Und da war so eine platte Fläche, wo man parken konnte, aber da standen so Radpanzer und APC.
Da habe ich gesagt, kann ich da parken? Ja, ja, deswegen habe ich so ein Foto,
wo mein Pickup neben so einem Radpanzer steht, einfach auf so einem Parkplatz.
Ich auch dachte, das hat man sonst auch nicht oft.
Und das war auch lustig, da hat sich niemand dran gestört, dass man da rumläuft,
da hat nicht mal einer gefragt, was ich da tue, also auch wieder so,
also wenn man nicht gefährlich wirkt oder sich nicht blöd anstellt,
kann man sich da gut bewegen, dann natürlich Journalisten in der Gegend,
Und das erste Mal, als ein Hotel bombardiert wurde, in dem ich vorher mal gewohnt
habe, war auch in Kramatorsk. Da hat uns irgendjemand gesagt,
hey, das Hotel, in dem du im Dezember warst, das gibt es nicht mehr.
Da ist ein S300 reingeflogen, aber es war zum Glück leer zu dem Zeitpunkt.
Und das fand ich so sehr krass. Und inzwischen ist es viermal passiert.
Also so, dass irgendwie auch die anderen Journalisten, die ich kenne,
die haben schon so eine Strichlist und sagen, ah, du warst auch mal in dem Jahr, ist ja auch schon weg.
Also es ist echt bizarr, was da so Alltag wird.
Und Kramatorsk hat halt auch einen großen Bahnhof, der ist ja auch 2022 schon,
wo auf die flüchtenden Leute eine Rakete geschossen.
Also das Übelste, was du echt irgendwie noch machen kannst, wenn du echt unmenschlich bist.
Das war deswegen halt auch sozusagen für die Dörfer drumherum und so der Evakuierungspunkt.
Und inzwischen, also zwischendurch, als ich da war, war es da echt wie ausgestorben.
Also man hat ein paar Soldaten gesehen und ein paar Journalisten und der Rest
war leer und ich weiß gar nicht, wie groß der Ort ist.
Ich tippe mal so 100.000 Einwohner oder 80.000, also eine Kleinstadt oder so,
so ganz grob würde ich meinen.
Und inzwischen kommen die Leute aber auch dahin wieder, obwohl es halt sozusagen
der nächste Ort zu Bachmuth ist, also 25, 20, 25 Kilometer.
Aber das ist gerade eben aus der Reichweite von der normalen Artillerie,
das sind so grob 20 Kilometer.
Das ist auch krass, so Dinge, die das normale Menschen da wissen.
Du sprichst mit einer auf der Straße und jeder sagt dir, aber Artillerie geht
ja nur so 20 Kilometer, also das ist sozusagen allgemein. Genau.
Und deswegen kommen da nach und nach Leute tatsächlich hin zurück,
also sodass da wieder ein Straßenleben stattfindet und Cafés und so einzelne aufhaben.
Du meintest, stört sich keiner dran, wenn du da rumläufst.
Ich frage mich die ganze Zeit, müsste es nicht auch ein großes Misstrauen gegenüber
so potenziellen russischen Spionen geben?
Also man hat ja immer wieder solche Fälle und jeder weiß ja auch,
dass es ja im Prinzip eine strategische Schwächung sein kann,
wenn so wichtige Orte ausspioniert werden, mit wo wird was repariert,
wo treffen sich internationale Hilfsgruppen oder irgendjemand,
der in irgendeiner Form kriegsentscheidend sein kann.
Ja, also mir schien, in vielen Gegenden ist es so, dass sie zu meinen E-Fahren
ausgehen, dass sie irgendwie ausspioniert werden.
Also ich meine, wie wenn man offen durch Kramatorsk läuft, man kann nicht verstecken,
was in der Stadt grundsätzlich los ist. Und ich glaube, das ist sowas,
womit sich viele abgefunden haben.
Dann war es so, an den Autos und so sind Presseschilder, also Englisch und Ukrainisch.
Das russische und das ukrainische Wort für Presse unterscheidet sich in einem Buchstaben.
Der hat uns vorgesagt, sieh zu, dass du das ukrainische drauf hast,
weil damit vermittelst du quasi, du kennst den Unterschied.
Also das gibt dir schon Pluspunkte.
Und, ähm, ich glaube, ist ein S und das andere zwei S oder irgendwie so.
Und, äh, dann halt, wenn wir in Gegenden waren, wo klar war,
das ist Frontnähe und, ähm, wir sind das erste Mal da, haben wir oft auch die
schusssicheren West mit den Presseschildern angehabt.
Also einfach, dass wenn jemand rumläuft, sagt, okay, wahrscheinlich ist das
Presse. Das ist grundsätzlich erstmal ein Grund, warum sie hier sind.
Und oft haben wir das aber auch nur kurz gehabt, so bis man dachte,
okay, das haben alle gesehen.
Dann die Schilder wieder ab, weil das halt auch nicht gut ist,
wenn man doch irgendwelche russischen Drohnen oder so in der Nähe hat,
weil die halt ganz gerne Journalisten zuerst abschießen, zumindest wenn sie
gerade ein bisschen Zeit haben und kein höherwertiges Ziel.
Und dann ist es aber oft so, also um in diese, also wie Kramatorsk zu der Zeit,
da durfte man halt auch nur hin mit einer Akkreditierung und ich habe halt die
Presseakkreditierung vom ukrainischen Verteidigungsministerium,
die muss ich alle sechs Monate erneuern und die wird dann an den Kontrollstellen,
an den Checkpoints davor kontrolliert.
Und die waren auch, man merkte sonst, manchmal hat man so auf den Autobahnen
oder auf so Landstraßen irgendwo einen Checkpoint, die sagen,
ah Presse, okay, fahr weiter.
Und vor Kramatorsk war es so, dass sie gesagt haben, okay, ich muss aber einmal
den Pass dazu sehen und ich muss einmal dein Gesicht genauer gucken,
ob das passt und kannst du bitte einmal kurz den Kopfraum aufmachen,
also immer sehr, sehr höflich, aber so nur, dass wir sehen, dass du da nicht
einen Raketenwerfer drin hast oder irgendwas. was.
Was man so dabei hat. Genau.
Und so grobe Sichtprüfung, okay, keine, also ist auch interessant,
weil die fragten immer, ob wir Waffen haben. Sagt, nö.
Dann habe ich mal nachher gefragt und sagten, ja, bei Ihnen ist es auch grundsätzlich
nicht verboten, dass Journalisten Waffen haben.
Also ist auch immer so ein Irrglaube, man dürfe das nicht, aber man darf halt
nicht an Kampfhandlung teilnehmen, aber die meisten Journalisten haben keine Waffen.
Aber deswegen fragen sie immer explizit, weil sie sagen, ja,
du bist Presse, das heißt aber nicht, dass du nicht doch eine waffenrechtliche
Erlaubnis hier haben könntest, deswegen fragen wir extra. Ja.
Und, also die Kontrollen waren so ein bisschen genauer, aber auch höflich.
Und ich kann mir vorstellen, wenn man dann in Kramatorsk ist,
dann geht man von aus, weil diese Kontrollen drumherum so genau sind,
dass ja irgendjemand einen schon kontrolliert haben wird.
Also irgendjemand hat schon nachgeguckt, ob du da sein darfst oder nicht.
Und mir scheint, dass es deswegen dann auch eigentlich geht.
Und ganz selten fragt halt meiner hier, für wen schreibst du oder was machst du?
Und dann ist halt immer gut, entweder die Printleute haben meist einfach ein
Magazin oder so bei und sagen hierfür.
Oder halt, dass man eben die Website da hat oder eine Visitenkarte und sagt hier.
Also Magazin ist ausgedruckt.
Das Presseerzeugnis.
Keine Patronenkurse.
Genau.
Und dass man dann halt sagt, hier, und was da auch immer wieder sozusagen Punkte
gibt, man sagt, aber ich komme ja seit zwei Jahren jeden Monat her.
Ich war schon da, ich war schon da.
Und sagen wir mal, manchmal, ganz selten merkt man, dass Leute so ein bisschen,
die wollen nicht unhöflich sein, aber sie wollen nachfragen,
ohne ein sozusagen, ohne grimmig zu sein.
Und dann habe ich halt auf dem Handy schon sowas wie die Best-of-Galerie,
Da sie sagt, guck mal, ich war da bei Butcher schon im April und dann waren
wir da in Saporica und so, dass man so ein bisschen wie die Selfie-Parade hat
und meist sagen sie dann, dann entspannt sich's und sie sagen, ja okay,
also man sieht, war immer wieder da, war immer da, wo so übliche Presse ist, ergibt irgendwie Sinn.
Plausibel.
Genau, also so. Und mehr hatte ich aber auch nie. Ich hatte einmal noch eine
ganz interessante Sache.
Da kam an einem so einem Checkpoint relativ weit vorne jemand vom Nachrichtendienst
und sagte auch ganz klar, hallo, ich bin vom Nachrichtendienst.
Und sagte, es tut mir jetzt sehr leid, aber ich muss einmal die E-Mails,
also sozusagen die Seriennummer von eurem Handy abfragen, damit wir gucken können,
wo ihr unterwegs wart, also ob ihr auf der russischen Seite wart.
Er sagt, okay, sagen wir, das ist nachvollziehbar und er erklärt es ja.
Und er kann es so oder so nachgucken, nur wenn ich ihm die E-Mail zeige,
geht es schneller und wenn ich es nicht mache, dann dauert das Ganze länger.
Und dann hat er das Handy genommen und sagte, ich kenne den Code,
aber hat es die ganze Zeit so gehalten, dass ich es sehen konnte.
Also nie irgendwas verdeckt gemacht und dann diese Codes irgendwie eingegeben,
damit die E-Mail direkt angezeigt wird.
Ja, da gibt es so eine Sternen-Karte-Kombination.
Ja, genau, irgendwie sowas. Hat sich die abgeschrieben und hat es mir wiedergegeben.
Also auch, dass man sieht, ich will nicht, mich interessiert nicht,
was auf deinem Handy ist. Ich will genau für den Zweck die E-Mail.
Und da dachte ich auch, okay, das ist aber transparent und in dem Fall nachvollziehbar.
Ist nicht irgendwie Vorratsdatenspeicherung in Deutschland oder so.
Und das fand ich aber auch interessant, so wie man da sagt, ja das ist okay,
weil mach halt, weil es ist eine spezielle Situation hier, aber dass die da
auch so relativ offen und klar sagen, was sie wollen und warum und nicht irgendwie,
wir müssen mal im Geheimen dein Handy checken, sondern das möchte ich, danke, gute Fahrt.
Ich glaube, es ist ja so schwer, sich das vorzustellen, was das für so ein Land
bedeutet, in so einer Kriegssituation zu sein.
Und ich denke, dass manche vielleicht auch davon ausgehen, dass in irgendeiner
Form dieses Staatswesen zum Erliegen gekommen ist oder zumindest stark eingeschränkt ist.
Ja.
Merkt man das?
Was war so dein Eindruck, wie resilient sozusagen der Staat als solcher funktioniert?
Also was ich spannend fand, wie schnell sie wieder klar gemacht haben,
dass der Start ganz normal funktioniert.
Also im März 2022 war zum Beispiel Straßenverkehr noch mehr so wie Anarchie.
Also als wir Ende März, Anfang April in Kiew fahren, war die Stadt fast leer
und uns wurde explizit gesagt, wenn ihr Auto fahrt, drückt das Gas bis zum Anschlag
durch, bis du da bist, wo du sein willst und dann rennen wir da rein.
Und da sind wir unglaublich schnell durch diese leeren Straßen in Kiew gefahren,
echt wie im Videospiel eher so.
Und eine Woche später, zwei Wochen später, als die Lage da sicherer wurde,
wurde wieder gesagt, okay, und jetzt machen wir das nicht mehr.
Und die fingen dann auch sofort an, wieder mit der Polizei Geschwindigkeitsmessungen zu machen.
Und so ein, zwei Tage haben sie einen nur rausgewunken und ganz böse ermahnt
und dann haben sie wieder die Bußgelder ganz normal genommen,
um auch zu sagen, hey, die Polizei ist noch da, es wird noch Geschwindigkeitskontrollen
gemacht, mein Auto ist mal abgeschleppt worden,
also so sozusagen aus deutscher Sicht an der Front quasi, aber es war halt sicher
in Kiew, weil ich halt falsch geparkt hatte und nicht mal, nicht mal sagen wir
richtig schlimm falsch,
sondern so einen Meter über eine Linie gestanden habe und sowas.
Und das, finde ich, zeigt ja aber auch so, hey, hier alles läuft ganz normal.
Es ist nichts Besonderes.
Selbst diese Sachen gehen noch. Und das fand ich schon interessant,
wie die da an so vielen Stellen drauf achten oder auch eben,
dass die Züge im Takt fahren und nicht, dass man sagt, es ist Krieg,
jeder fährt, wie er will, sondern. Also.
Nicht so wie bei uns.
Weil der Wagen. Ja.
Weil der Wagen gebrannt hat. Das funktioniert.
Es tut uns leid für die Unannehmlichkeiten, dass ihr Wagen bombardiert wurde,
aber die drei Euro Reservierungsgebühr ist erstattet.
Und der fuhr dann nach Lviv und da war der halbe Bahnhof voll Journalisten,
weil alle jetzt dachten, na wie im Zombiefilm kommt da jetzt der kaputte Zug
sechs Stunden verspätet und sie kamen, wenn ich es richtig im Kopf habe,
mit zehn Minuten Verspätung ab,
weil sie halt den Bombenschaden noch reparieren und den Zug löschen mussten
und haben sich dann entschuldigt, dass sie jetzt zehn Minuten Verspätung haben
wegen einem Raketenangriff.
Und ich dachte, okay, das ist eine ganz andere Ebene, wie die damit umgehen
Und zum anderen, mit sowas kann man natürlich exzellent auch in den Medien spielen,
dass man das so noch so überspitzt sagt, tut uns so leid, dass wir zehn Minuten
gebraucht haben, um den Raketenschaden zu reparieren, aber sonst ist ja alles okay.
Aber das halt ganz viele so Dinge, wo sie halt immer rausstellen,
erstmal, wir kommen damit klar.
An sich herrscht hier Normalheit, also das ist kein, also das ist ein Grund
zu spät zu kommen, aber jetzt fangen nicht alle an zu heulen und sagen,
wie schrecklich, sondern man sagt, ja und der Zug fährt weiter und jetzt,
scheiß Rakete vergeudet, ne, hat gar nicht geklappt, Zug fährt noch und das
finde ich halt so irre, wie das, aber mir scheint so durch quasi alle Bereiche
der Gesellschaft und so geht.
Eine Sache, das war auch nur, weil es da so reinpasst, wir waren in Saporica,
also da, wo quasi gegenüber das vermiente Atomkraftwerk Enahoda ist und wir
wollten halt gucken, wie schlimm und desolat ist die Lage, wenn du quasi dem
dritten Weltkrieg gegenüber sitzt so.
Und dann wollte ich abends so ein paar Sachen dazu runterschreiben im Hotel
und ich konnte nicht schreiben, weil draußen eine Party lief,
die so laut war, dass ich mich kaum konzentrieren konnte.
Ich dachte, stell dir vor, du bist Russland, du vermienst das Atomkraftwerk,
nimmst das ein, willst Terror über das ganze Land bringen und gegenüber siehst
du die Lichter von der Disco und die Leute feiern einfach und es interessiert sie überhaupt nicht.
Ich glaube, das ist das Schlimmste, was was dir passieren kann,
dass die einfach weitermachen und sagen, schön, aber hier ist Party.
Die Partykultur muss sowieso unglaublich sein.
Man kennt das ja generell aus Erzählungen von immer wenn so der Untergang nah ist,
dann gibt es halt gerade bei der Jugend so den Druck mit, okay,
dann feiern wir jetzt aber auch wirklich, als ob es keinen Morgen gäbe,
weil vielleicht gibt es ja auch keinen Morgen und das kann die Party dann schon
mal ganz ordentlich aufladen.
Es gibt auch so Initiativen, wo Gruppen von Jugendlichen so quasi durchs Land
ziehen in ehemals zerstörte,
Gebiete, also wo sich jetzt das russische Militär zurückgezogen hat,
also sowas wie Butscher etc.,
wo halt einzelne Häuser dann halt repariert werden und die dann sozusagen sich
dort dann im Kollektiv niederlassen und freiwillig und kostenlos für die die
Leute diese Häuser wieder aufbauen und während sie das machen, steht da so ein DJ,
daneben und es wird einfach die ganze Zeit irgendwie gefeiert.
Das fand ich irgendwie bemerkenswert.
Ja, das ist unglaublich. Es gab auch gerade in Kiew, also gibt es ja eine Menge
Clubs und Nachtclubs und so und als die Ausgangssperre war, also die gibt es
immer noch, aber die war früher länger, jetzt kürzer.
Ich glaube, zur Zeit ist die von 23 bis 5 Uhr oder so und wenn du im Club bist,
sagen die so um 22.30 Uhr Leute 30 Minuten bis Ausgangssperre,
also Also geh jetzt oder du musst bis fünf durchfeiern. Das sind so die zwei Optionen.
Ganz einfach. Aber damit ist das Problem gelöst.
Ja, ich wollte mal kurz auf die Züge zurückkommen, weil ich die ganz wichtig
finde in Bezug auf, wie funktioniert das Land.
Also du hast ja auch schon gesagt, Züge sind generell eine wichtige Infrastruktur,
die in der Ukraine schon immer sehr ernst genommen wurde.
Keine Ahnung, wie das früher lief, aber jetzt ist es halt auch einfach nochmal wichtiger.
Ich glaube Selensky hat einen relativ jungen Menschen zu Beginn des Krieges
dort zum Chef gemacht, so nach dem Motto, hier sorgt mal dafür, dass der Laden läuft,
weil es natürlich jetzt nicht nur darum geht eine Normalität herzustellen,
sondern natürlich die Eisenbahninfrastruktur auch super wichtig ist für die
gesamte Kriegslogistik natürlich.
Ja und was lustig ist, den haben sie dann nach einem Jahr oder anderthalb Jahren,
ich weiß gar nicht, da sozusagen wieder rausgenommen, damit er sich um Munitionsfabriken kümmert.
Also so nach dem Motto, okay, Züge fahren, top Job, wir haben hier die nächste
Baustelle für dich, weil du kriegst offensichtlich Dinge gemanagt.
Genau und das bringt mich so ein bisschen auf diesen Punkt,
um so einen Staat unter Stress quasi zum Laufen zu bringen, ist die Personalpolitik
der Regierung glaube ich sehr wichtig und vielleicht die wichtigste Kontribution,
die Zelensky sozusagen mit seiner Regierung machen kann, mal abgesehen von einem
ganzen internationalen diplomatischen Parkett.
Das scheint ja zu gelingen.
Auf der anderen Seite wird dem Land ja auch nach wie vor ein hoher Grad an Korruption
unterstellt und es gibt ja auch immer wieder Fälle und es mussten ja schon so
auch einige Minister zurücktreten.
Was hatten wir jetzt als letztes gerade diese Woche? Musste doch auch jemand seinen Hut nehmen.
Weiß jetzt gerade nicht. Auf jeden Fall passiert. Also was ist deine Wahrnehmung
davon, wie das so wahrgenommen wird?
Ist das ein Thema, worüber die Leute reden?
Ist das so etwas, was man vielleicht eher verdrängend nicht wahrhaben will?
War das wirklich so, dass das immer ein großes Problem war oder ist das eigentlich
auch nur so ein russisches Propagandamotiv, was über Europa gestreut wird,
um die Unterstützung für die Ukraine zu unterlassen?
Ne, Korruption war immer ein Riesending dort, also auf allen Ebenen,
also galt halt immer als das korrupteste Land Europas und ich kann mich nicht
mehr erinnern, dass die Ukrainer dazu gesagt hätten, das stimmt nicht.
Also zumindest war das wohl so von allen Beteiligten nahm man das an.
Und als das mit dem Krieg losging,
Und war es halt auch so, dass die Korruption gerade im Verteidigungsministerium
oder in den Beschaffungsprozessen und so ist, was mich im Prinzip so fertig
macht, wo ich denke, ihr kämpft da ums Überleben vom Land.
Wie kann da jemand noch die Hand aufhalten? Also irgendwann muss man doch merken,
dass das jetzt der falsche Zeitpunkt ist.
Das sitzt aber so tief. Ich glaube, das ist halt wie so ein Krebsgespür.
Das dauert so lange, bis du den letzten davon erwischt hast.
Aber ich kenne selber Leute, die Rüstungsgüter an die Ukraine angeboten haben
oder sogar geliefert haben, die sich alle beschwert haben, dass es immer auf
irgendeiner Ebene Korruption gab oder zumindest den Wunsch danach.
Nach und sie haben es dann auch der Korruptionsstelle gemeldet,
NABU und das hat wohl auch immer wieder Früchte getragen.
Also das dann nach Wochen bis Monaten, das dauert ja so eine Ermittlung,
aber die Person, mit der sie zu tun hatten, auf einmal nicht mehr da war.
Aber dann gab es irgendwie eine Ebene höher wieder ein oder woanders ein und
sagen, das ist halt das Problem, die machen wirklich viel dagegen,
aber es gibt einfach unglaublich viele Fälle auf verschiedenen Ebenen.
Und das andere Problem ist wie immer, wenn man Wenn man es jetzt aus Business-Sicht
sieht, wenn man an der Korruption dann als Zulieferer nicht teilnimmt,
hat man halt keinen Auftrag.
Und der, der den Auftrag hat, hat offensichtlich mitgemacht,
aber hat auch kein Problem, weil er hat ja den Auftrag.
Was halt auch so sozusagen, das hindert einen daran, diese Korruption loszuwerden,
wenn es immer welche gibt, die am Ende dran verdienen oder die willens sind,
in irgendeiner Form mitzuspielen, weil sie auch was von haben.
Und von der Bevölkerung, das fand ich das Interessanteste, Selensky ist ja damals mit,
ich glaube, was waren das, 60, 70 Prozent der Stimmen gewählt worden,
aber ich habe nie das Gefühl gehabt, dass 70 Prozent des Landes ihn mögen,
sondern dass er halt die beste Wahl war, aber nicht sozusagen der Top-Kandidat, den alle haben wollten.
Und was ich ganz, ganz oft höre ist, dass sie sagen, sie mögen den nicht,
sie haben eine Menge Probleme mit ihm, aber das, was er jetzt gerade macht,
ist hervorragend und alle Probleme können sie besprechen, wenn der Krieg vorbei ist.
Also jetzt macht er einen guten Job, das ist okay, aber sie haben noch eine
Rechnung offener, die ist nach hinten geschoben, wenn diese Nummer rum ist.
Was ist das für eine Rechnung?
Dass sie halt sagen, also Korruption, dass es halt immer heißt,
also egal was er tut offensichtlich, gibt es noch welche, da müsste man irgendwie
viel strenger noch mehr machen.
Dann halt die Vorwürfe bei ihm mit Steuerhinterziehung und sowas,
dass halt viele auch sagen, nö, das ist nicht okay, also ich zahl Steuern.
Sollte das stimmen, dass er die nicht gezahlt hat, ist das auch nicht okay,
also den will ich dann nicht auf Dauer.
Der ist glaube ich in diesen Panama-Apps genannt worden. Genau.
Und eine Menge so Sachen. Also es gibt verschiedene Punkte, die Leute nicht
an ihm mögen, aber in erster Linie so Korruption, Vetternwirtschaft und sowas.
Und nicht mal, dass Leute mir gesagt haben, dass sie meinen,
dass er da wirklich Finger im Spiel hat oder so.
Also, aber dass sie einfach sagen, aber es wäre ja sein Job,
das sozusagen komplett auszumerzen und das schneller und es gibt immer wieder
Vorwürfe, er wüsste doch hiervon und davon, das wird man wahrscheinlich nie klären können.
Aber so das, also wirklich so das Gängige, was ich höre, ist,
der soll jetzt super den Job weitermachen, weil der macht das exzellent,
aber ob ich ihn danach nochmal wähle, müssen wir dann gucken.
Soweit ich weiß, will er danach auch gar nicht mehr antreten,
also das ergibt sich, glaube ich, von alleine.
Und ich glaube, das wäre das Schlauste, was er machen kann. Also nicht dieses
Machtgeile und Haften, was dann ja manche haben.
Wenn der sozusagen, wie auch immer, der Krieg dann genau vorbeigeht,
aber irgendwie, wenn die Sache halbwegs sinnvoll durch ist und er sagt,
danke und jetzt gehe ich, dann wird er auf ewig der Held sein.
Das ist so, wo ich denke, hätte Kohl nicht diese schwarzen Kassen gehabt,
dann wäre er nur immer der Kanzler der Einheit und egal wie doof man ihn damals fand,
das wäre sein Vermächtnis gewesen und dann okay und dann noch die schwarzen
Kassen und da denke ich, wenn Selenskyj schlau genug ist,
das wäre das Beste, dann bauen die ihm Star-Touren und alle feiern ihn und sagen
okay, das ist ein fairer Deal, wenn du gehst, wenn die Sache durch ist und alles vergessen.
Also da gehe ich von aus, dass das sowas wäre, wo wie immer,
also die Geschichte wird ja am Ende geschrieben und dann wird man sagen,
ach das war alles vorher, aber er hat den Krieg gewonnen oder uns da gut durchgebracht, alles okay.
Ja, ich denke, alles andere würde mich ein bisschen überraschen als Ausgang tatsächlich.
Die internationale Wahrnehmung, da kommen wir auch gleich nochmal drauf,
ist natürlich ganz klar,
dass er eigentlich das Gesicht dieses gesamten Konflikts ist im Westen und er
diese Rolle international einfach auf Ewigkeiten auch haben wird.
Egal was da im Detail vielleicht mal war oder so. Ja.
Und die tollen Memes, das muss man ja sagen, kein Krieg hat solche schönen Memes gebracht.
Es gibt halt immer noch dieses, wo er durch eine Lagerhalle oder einen Supermarkt
oder auf so einem Gabelstapler nackt rumfährt, eins von seinen alten Sketch-Videos.
Das gab es, da sieht man ihn so ein paar Sekunden so rumfahren und dann steht
er und der hat den Krieg gewonnen.
Also das wirst du sonst nie wieder haben. Ja, das stimmt.
Das vergisst man ja auch schnell, dass er wirklich aus einer Theaterrolle sozusagen
in die richtige Rolle gekommen ist.
Diese ganze Story ist unfassbar.
Und aber auch so, ich finde das sozusagen, was es noch so auf die Spitze treibt,
dass er so übelsten Klamauk auch gemacht
hat, also nicht so ein seriöser Schauspieler, sondern so, weiß nicht,
vielleicht wie Harpe Kerkling oder Otto oder so vom Spaßniveau her oder sowas.
So wie man jetzt sagen würde, okay und Harpe Kerkling hat jetzt den Krieg gegen
Russland gewonnen oder so und sagt, okay, das hätte ich nicht erwartet, aber okay.
Es gibt auch schöne Bilder von irgendeiner Veranstaltung, wo tatsächlich Putin
auch auf demselben Event war und so.
Also da ist viel Gold zu finden, wenn man da gräbt.
Ich wollte jetzt nochmal, du hast es ja schon kurz angerissen,
du warst ja auch in Saporischia.
Saporischia ist Hauptstadt der Region in Saporischia und eben der Ort,
wo der Dnipro-Fluss, der von Kiew kommt nach Süden in das ehemalige große Dnipro-Becken
fließt, das ja nur existierte,
weil es eben den Staudamm gab,
den die Russen jetzt vor einem Fasten gesprengt haben.
Und als du da warst, war er ja schon gesprengt.
Genau.
Wie sieht es da aus? Wie kann man sich das denn jetzt vorstellen?
Weil das ist ja im Prinzip auch so ein großes Fragezeichen.
Da, wo jetzt quasi vorher fast schon so ein Binnenmeer war,
ist jetzt im Prinzip der natürliche Flusslauf ja wieder hergestellt,
in Anführungsstrichen, weil das natürlich alles so überschwemmt war,
dass das sich jetzt nicht von heute auf morgen wie ein normales Land anfühlen dürfte.
Ja, es war ja, also der Dnipro war da ja, meine ich, auf einer ganzen,
auf einer langen Fläche so mehrere Kilometer breit. Ich weiß gar nicht,
fünf oder sowas oder noch mehr. Also so, dass man wirklich das Ende kaum sehen kann.
Und Saporica war die letzte Stadt, bevor sozusagen dieser See oder dieses Staubecken
oder wie man es nennen will, anfängt.
Und als ich dann in Saporica war, war der Fluss halt tief und das erste,
was wir gesehen haben, war, es gab wie so einen Anlegersteg,
der ins Wasser ging, aber so ein betonierter, so ein richtig stabiler.
Und wo halt so wie Ausflugsschiffe oder sowas früher angelegt haben.
Und der stand einfach komplett im Trocknen.
Also der ganze Steg stand im Trocknen.
Also der ganze Weg hin. Und am Ende, wenn man runtergeguckt hat,
hat man bestimmt zehn Meter da so runtergeguckt.
Und unten war wie so eine Pfütze das Wasser nur.
Und da waren ein paar Angler. Und die haben gesagt, das ist super geil.
Die gleiche Menge Fische. Aber der Fluss ist halt nur noch irgendwie so schmal.
Da kannst du quasi mit der Hand die Fische rausholen.
Ja.
Und ein Stück weiter war so ein Nebenarm oder ein Zufluss oder was weiß ich
was, sozusagen im Süden von Saporica, der nach Osten so weg geht.
Und da war ein Schwimmbad und so ein, ja auch wie so ein kleiner See oder wirklich
wie so ein Teich oder sowas, an dem es früher ein paar Cafés mit so schwimmenden Terrassen gab. ab.
Und das war, dieses ganze Becken war trocken und da waren auch so zwei,
drei wie so Restaurant- oder Café-Schiffe, die einfach auf dem Trockenen lagen, also auf dem Grund.
Und diese schwimmenden Terrassen lagen sozusagen am Abhang einfach schräg runter
und der ganze Fluss, der da Zufluss war, da gab es so eine kleine Eisenbahnbrücke
drüber und da war auch kein Fluss mehr.
Dann habe ich auch die ganze Zeit erstmal Google Maps angemacht und Google Earth
halt und Und geguckt, wie sah das denn hier vorher aus, weil man sich das ja nicht vorstellen kann.
Und dann gesehen, hey, die Brücke, auf der ich stehe, da ist eigentlich ein
Fluss drunter, nur ist der Fluss nicht da.
Und das ist schon sehr, sehr, sehr bizarr, weil man es da, also ich meine,
wenn so ein Riesensee ein Stück Meter in Höhe oder so verliert,
dann nimmt man das ja nicht so direkt wahr.
Aber wenn da so ein kleinerer Fluss ist und der ist einfach weg,
dann sieht man halt, der ist jetzt weg.
Und dann sind wir halt bis an dieses Staubecken gefahren.
Also wir haben vorher so ein bisschen geguckt, wo kommt man da wirklich ans
Wasser? Also wo stapft man nicht durch den Garten von jemandem,
sondern wo kann man so ganz grob diagonal gegenüber von Enarhoda oder so stehen
und halt mal so rübergucken und genau da gegenüber kommt man nicht hin.
Also waren wir so, ich weiß nicht, vielleicht 20, 10 Kilometer,
20 Kilometer da so östlich davon, Also so im Nichts, wo da so Felder und sowas sind.
Und da gab es halt eine Stelle, die sah so aus, wie wenn man da seine Boote
früher zu Wasser gelassen hat oder so eine Straße, die sozusagen ins Wasser
runter geht mit so einer Menge Spuren vom Rangieren. Genau.
Nur war diese Rampe halt im Trockenen und sie endete im Trockenen und dann kam
noch irgendwie so ein bisschen vom Strand sozusagen und dann erst der See.
Und das ist so ein bisschen schwierig zu verstehen, glaube ich,
wenn man es sonst nicht kennt, weil der See hat offensichtlich ein paar Meter an Höhe verloren,
was dann ja an Volumen unglaublich viel ist, aber für uns war halt immer noch
Wasser zu sehen und dann ist halt schwierig eine Relation zu haben,
ist das jetzt besonders viel, ist das wenig, was fehlt hier?
Und das andere Interessante war, dass das halt alles vermint war.
Also da war auch so ein bisschen Zaun. Man muss sich daran gewöhnen,
dass Minenfelder nicht gut markiert sind.
Also da ist so ein kleiner Zaun und da hängt so ein rotes Dreieck dran.
Und dann muss man halt wissen, dass das ein Minenfeld ist. Und sonst merkt man
es bestimmt, wenn man rüberklettert.
Und da haben wir gesagt, okay, Strand vermint, alles okay.
Da haben wir erstmal davor Fotos gemacht, wie man das so macht.
Und dann haben wir halt so ein dumpfes Grollen irgendwie gehört und dann waren
da so Leute, die haben so ein Stück weiter gewohnt und die haben dann gesagt, ey,
nix gegen euch, aber die schießen jetzt mit Artillerie, also haltet die Augen auf.
Okay, dann fahren wir erstmal wieder ein Stück weiter. Oh Mann.
Zu erfassen. Dann eben hatten wir da gewartet, als diese ersten Satellitenbilder
kamen und man es da so ein bisschen besser verstehen konnte, wie viel fehlt.
Ist aber auch wieder so eine Sache, die, wenn man da steht, also da,
wo der Fluss ausgetrocknet war, okay, das war sehr gut zu sehen.
Und da, wo dieser See aber einfach Meter an Höhe verloren hat,
das war sozusagen unbeeindruckender schwer zu erfassen, wenn man halt den Vergleich zu vorher nicht hat.
Also das fand ich immer so komisch, wenn man so denkt, das geht durch die Weltpresse,
wie es da ist und wenn man da steht, sagt man, okay, wo genau ist der Unterschied,
weil ich weiß nicht, was ich hier sehen muss.
Und was war jetzt dein, ich meine, es war, wie lange nachdem der Staudamm, ein.
Zwei Monate schon später?
Ja genau.
Zwei, glaube ich, also schon als das sozusagen das Wasser abgelassen war.
Aber das war noch nicht alles abgelaufen, oder?
Ich muss sagen, das weiß ich gar nicht, weil ich mir auch nicht sicher bin, wie lange braucht das.
Bis so ein Stausee abläuft. Ich hatte so die Einschätzung gehört,
wenn ich mich richtig erinnere, dass das dann schon mal so drei Monate dauern
kann, bis das sich ausgedient hat. Ja.
Dann war es irgendwie da so am
Ende. Also dann war das wahrscheinlich irgendwo da in den letzten Zügen.
Also wie gesagt, ein Teil war halt schon weg und ein Teil war schwer zu erkennen für mich.
Und jetzt hat man da sozusagen so riesige freigelegte Gebiete,
wo unter Umständen Seeminen im Schlick sind, die dann einfach mit abgesoffen,
sondern aufgetaucht sind. Wobei.
Die sieht man ja. Seeminen sind ja relativ groß, also echt so wie man die aus
Museum oder so kennt, so einen halben Meter bis einen Meter Durchmesser oder so. so.
Das fiese sind halt die, also die sind ja deswegen markiert,
die neu verlegten, die Personenminen oder Panzerminen, die sind halt,
die sieht man nicht, die sind irgendwo unterm Sand.
Die jetzt sozusagen nochmal nachträglich.
Genau, aber deswegen sind sie halt markiert. Ah, das bringt auch,
weil ich das so ein lustiges Problem fand, das bringt manchmal ganz simple Probleme.
Wir sind eine Straße lang gefahren, eine Spur pro Richtung, also man konnte
nicht einfach anhalten, weil man dann jemanden blockiert hätte.
Und rechts und links war Minenfeld und wir mussten beide ganz dringend pinkeln.
Ja, was jetzt? Und das hörte nicht auf, dass Minenfeld sagt sowas,
das sind Dinge, die lernt man nicht auf der Journalistenschule oder so.
Das merkt man dann, was es für doofe Probleme in diesen Gegenden gibt.
Aber deswegen, es ist manchmal so, das ist so komisch, dass so Minen,
die da im Schlick liegen, machen einem zumindest im Alltag kleine Probleme,
aber Aber wenn man muss und die Straße ist schmal, dann schon.
Also es ist sehr merkwürdig, was dann sozusagen im Alltag die Schwierigkeit
ist und der Unterschied zwischen Theorie und Praxis.
Jetzt warst du zuletzt kurz vor Weihnachten nochmal in der Ukraine,
ich glaube in Kharkiv nochmal.
Ihr habt da irgendwie Weihnachtsgeschenke verteilt.
Und jetzt ist ja dieser Krieg schon gut zwei Jahre alt, also wir nähern uns
ja jetzt auch bald dem traurigen Jubiläum.
Das macht ja was mit allem, wenn man so lange in dieser Situation ist.
Es wird ja auch viel darüber diskutiert, so Kriegsmütigkeit und solche Begriffe.
Ich meine, es ist ja nicht so, dass man sich das Kriegsmütigkeit irgendwie auch
nur erlauben könnte, weil in dem Moment, wo man einschläft, wird es ja eigentlich erst schwierig.
Das heißt, man ist eigentlich, so stelle ich mir das vor, eigentlich unter so
einem permanenten Stress, weil man diese Habachtstellung eigentlich so nie verlassen kann.
Egal wie sehr man sich ablenkt und wie sehr man die Nicht-Normalität als Normalität abnimmt.
An dem, was war denn dann so jetzt zuletzt dein Eindruck, wie viel davon wirklich real ist?
Oder hält dieser Trotz, es wird ja auch viel darüber diskutiert,
jetzt müsste sich das Militär verstärken, aber viele sind geflohen,
viele wollen dann vielleicht auch nicht kämpfen,
was dann natürlich noch mehr Druck auf die Soldaten nimmt, die jetzt an der
Front sind, weil die dann nicht mehr in dem Maße ausgetauscht werden können,
Wodurch die ja dann wiederum noch mehr ermüden.
Ist die Ukraine jetzt da an so einem kritischen Punkt oder gibt es da irgendeinen
unerschöpflichen Vorrat an Resilienz und jetzt erst recht?
Das Hauptproblem, glaube ich, liegt darin, dass wir halt von ukrainischer Seite
ja keine Zahlen haben über genaue Verluste und über die genaue Menge in der Armee und so.
Und das ist, dadurch kann man halt nur mutmaßen oder so anekdotische Evidenz
halt irgendwie anführen.
Was ich von den Leuten vor Ort gehört habe, die alles möglich mit Crowdfunding machen,
ist nur, dass die Spenden im Vergleich zum ersten Monat von der Invasion zu
heute um ungefähr 98 Prozent zurückgegangen sind.
Also die sitzen fast alle auf dem Trockenen und kriegen kein Crowdfunding mehr
für medizinische Produkte oder ich weiß nicht was hin.
Was ja am Anfang so der Crowdfunding-Krieg war. Und jetzt, also in der gesamten
Masse ist es richtig abgefallen.
Dann im Land oder bei den Ukrainern scheint mir habe ich so drei Hauptgruppen
oder wie man es nennen will erlebt.
Das eine eben die, die direkt geflohen sind und zum Teil auch noch bis heute weg sind.
Das waren halt ganz oft junge Frauen und oft mit den Kindern,
also jung im Sinne von so, weiß nicht, bis 30, 35 sagen wir mal,
aber das schien mir eine große Gruppe und sozusagen das Fatale für die Ukraine,
meist so anpassungsfähige, gut ausgebildete Leute.
Und es ist halt wie immer, wenn man top ausgebildet ist und flexibel und woanders
hingeht, dann macht man da einfach weiter und dann wird es schwierig,
also irgendwann in Zukunft für die Ukraine die Leute zurückzuholen,
weil du musst ihnen ja irgendwas bieten, was besser ist als das,
was sie jetzt sich aufgebaut haben.
Ja, viele sind dann hier so in ein Deutschland mit Fachkräftemangel gekommen
und mal abgesehen von den generellen Problemen, die wir so mit Flüchtlingen
haben, finden die ja hier eigentlich optimale Bedingungen. Ja.
Und halt gerade, also ich kenne halt welche, also so die klassischen aus IT-Berufen
oder so, gut, denen meistens ja egal, wo sie arbeiten oder so,
wenn es eine Pizza-App gibt, kann man die irgendwo hinsetzen und dann arbeiten sie los.
Aber auch Künstler und aber auch ganz normale Office-Kräfte oder sowas.
Aber ich meine, ja, Fachkräftemangel hast du überall.
Und eben, wenn du, also ganz einfach, wenn du Arbeitgeber bist und da kommt
jemand, der ist engagiert und der hat Bock, dann ist das ja schon 80 Prozent
von dem, was du willst. Und den Rest kriegst du hin.
So, dann die Leute, die im Land geblieben sind, das ist so die zweite große Gruppe, klar.
Und da scheint mir, dass aber bei ganz vielen so echt Normalität eingetreten
ist im Alltag. Also die gehen wieder ihrer Arbeit nach, die gehen in Clubs,
die gehen in Cafés und klar hat man den Krieg.
Aber jetzt speziell in Kiew und westlich davon hat man halt relativ wenig mit zu tun.
Und selbst wenn man dann hier mal wieder liest, da ist wieder eine Drohne in
Kiew runtergekommen, ja.
Aber das ist so, wie wenn du in Berlin liest, es wurde jemand im Park abgestochen
und sagt, ja, das ist schlimm, aber ich habe nichts mitgekriegt und ich kenne den nicht.
Gasexplosion in Rolo.
Ja, genau. Das betrifft einen halt nicht.
Wobei das natürlich auch nur teilweise so stimmt, weil ich glaube,
es gibt in der Ukraine mittlerweile niemanden mehr, der nicht jemanden kennt
oder in der Familie hat, der in irgendeiner Form Schaden genommen hat.
Genau, nur da muss man traurigerweise sagen, beim ersten Mal ist das ganz schlimm und schrecklich.
Beim zweiten Mal nimmt es ab. Also es ist wirklich ein unglaublicher Gewöhnungseffekt.
Ich erinnere mich, als das erste Mal jemand gestorben ist, den ich einen Tag
vorher gesehen hatte, also vor langer Zeit in einem Kriegsgebiet.
Da war ich ziemlich fertig danach, weil ich dachte so, ich habe den gerade noch gesprochen und so.
Das war alles aber nicht in Afghanistan.
Also da gibt es nicht mal mehr eine Trauerzeit oder so. Und das ist,
scheint mir in der Ukraine leider auch so, dass man so einen gewissen Gewöhnungseffekt
hat, also wie bei allem im Leben.
Und sozusagen die dritte große Gruppe von denen in der Ukraine,
oder die ist dann nicht mehr so groß.
Aber die, die entweder Soldaten oder Freiwillige sind oder auch Rettungskräfte
oder so, also die, die wirklich an der Front aktiv sind und alle,
zu denen ich da Kontakt habe,
sind immer noch motiviert, egal wie schlimm es ist.
Also das finde ich so krass. Die sagen, hey, mir ist egal, ob die anderen jetzt
zur Armee gehen oder nicht oder so. Ich mache hier trotzdem weiter.
Ich hätte gern mehr Rotation. Ich würde gern mehr freimachen.
Aber davon höre ich ja nicht auf, hier meine Pflicht sozusagen zu tun.
Also dass sie sagen, ja, das ist assi von denen, wenn die sozusagen sich drum drücken.
Aber das ändert nichts daran, dass ich hier das Richtige mache.
Und es gibt auch so bizarre Sachen. Ich kenne eine Ärztin, Die ist jetzt,
ich glaube, 23 oder so und die an einem Stabilisierungspunkt arbeitet.
Also noch bevor man sozusagen ins Lazarett kommt, also das so,
was hier der Notarzt oder so machen würde beim Autounfall.
Also so jemanden transportfähig machen, damit er dann erst richtig versorgt
wird. Also echt das Allerübelste.
Und mit der schreibe ich immer wieder, so auf WhatsApp. Und die sagte dann zum
Beispiel, ja, sie mussten jetzt wieder ihren Stabilisierungspunkt umziehen,
weil der alte bombardiert wurde.
Und dann kommt nicht mal eine Meldung, ob jemandem was passiert ist oder so,
sondern mussten halt umziehen.
Und dann habe ich halt gefragt, sind die anderen okay? Ja, also so ein paar
Verletzte, aber kein Tote.
Also das ist so, aber das Umziehen ist das Problem, nicht, dass wie jeden Tag Leute verletzt werden.
Also das ist schon so gar nicht mehr erwähnenswert.
Und bei der ist es so lustig, wenn man so die Fotos von ihr sieht,
die sieht halt auch nicht aus wie so eine Kämpferin oder so,
sondern so ein ganz liebes, nettes, irgendwie, also fast wie Mädchen noch,
also so ein ganz junges Gesicht halt.
Und die schickt dann immer wieder Fotos, weil die machen so lustige Fotos dann, das ist unglaublich.
Also ist so in einem Keller, also eins von den Bildern und da ist so,
naja, wie so ein Bett oder so, auf dem sie jemanden operiert hat und der hat
halt Arm verbunden und kopfblutig und alles.
Und dann grinsen sie beide in die Kamera und halten Daumen hoch.
Und man sagt so, so Fotos macht ihr da.
Oder auch so was, ähm,
Auch ein anderes Foto, wo sie halt irgendwie mit Leuten ist,
die so, die hatten Brandverletzungen, die haben den Kopf verbunden und den Oberkörper
verbunden und erstmal der eine von denen sieht wirklich aus wie mumifiziert, aber raucht,
weil Kippe geht noch gerade eben durch und sie steht daneben und zieht Kremassen
und solche Bilder dann, wo man sagt,
okay, also die halten trotzdem ihre Laune, ne, also so das finde ich so absolut
abgefahren, wie das so, also es sieht aus wie so ein schlechter Photoshop,
als hättest du so den einen von der Party ins Kriegsgebiet gefotoshopt.
Aber so da denke ich, gut, wenn die das noch hinkriegen, ist doch,
also besser geht es nicht, wenn man noch immer irgendwie den Spaß rausholen
kann, selbst in so einer üblen Lage.
Und das finde ich nur so abgefahren, wie die so die Laune behalten können.
Oder auch, wenn ich zum Beispiel medizinische Produkte oder so mitgebracht habe
und Leuten, die irgendwie für ihre Einheit oder sowas brauchen oder für irgendwelche
Medics, die da unterwegs sind.
Dann schicken die eigentlich immer nachher Fotos, wo sie die gebraucht haben
oder wo die gelandet sind, sozusagen als Nachweis, hey, danke für deine,
keine Ahnung, für das Verbandsmaterial und hier ist es auch wirklich gelandet,
also dass du wirklich weißt, das ist in guten Händen.
Und die Leute da auch, die machen da meist auch noch irgendwelchen Blödsinn
damit oder einer hat mit so ein paar Mullbinden jongliert und sowas und so ein Kram gemacht, aber,
sozusagen nicht, wie man sich hier vorstellen würde, wie man hat so eine Checklist
und da hakt man ab, wir haben drei Mullbinden ausgeliefert, sondern sie machen
dann lustige Fotos damit oder sowas und das,
also da merke ich dann nur immer wieder so, wenn man ein bisschen mehr Kontakt
zu den Leuten hat, wie dieser Humor oder so, wie sie sich den noch halten.
Oder auch bei einer anderen Kollegin, die ist Journalistin.
Also sie ist Ukrainerin und Journalistin und viel an der Front.
Die macht dauernd Fotos mit irgendwelchen Tieren, die sie da finden.
Also Hunde, Katzen, so Haustiere, die dann die Nähe suchen, weil niemand mehr
da ist, zu dem sie gehört haben.
Und da lernt man dann auf einmal so spannende Details. Und sie sagte zum Beispiel,
in den Schützengräben kennt sie viele, die die Katzen auch füttern und die in der Nähe halten.
Weil die Katzen haben irgendwann gelernt, wenn sie ein bestimmtes Geräusch hören,
was die Katze halt hört, bevor du es hörst, kurz darauf knallt es.
Das hat die Katze nach zwei, dreimal gelernt.
Das heißt, auf einmal rennen alle Katzen weg und man weiß, ey,
in drei Sekunden höre ich die Artillerie pfeifen, aber die Katze hat es jetzt schon gehört.
Früh waren sie es.
Ja genau und sagen so ein paar Sekunden machen da ja dann den Unterschied und
sagen die Katzen lernen das von selbst ganz schnell, was dieses Pfeifen heißt.
Und das fand ich nur auch spannend, weil das hat man sozusagen nicht in der
Headline oder nicht in den großen Artikeln, weil das dafür so zu klein ist.
Und wenn man halt diesen Kontakt hat und hält, dann hat man auf einmal ganz
viele so kleine Details, wo man sagt, oh, das ist schon spannend, so je tiefer das geht.
Also was halt nicht so mit den großen Militärbewegungen oder Taurus oder nichts
zu tun hat, sondern mit den ganz praktischen Dingen da vorne.
Ja, ich habe viele solche Videos gesehen von Katzen in Katzengräben,
wo sich die Soldaten um die Katzen kümmern.
Das ist natürlich jetzt nochmal ein Aspekt, den ich so betrachtet habe,
wobei ich auch glaube, dass dieses ganze Umgehen mit solchen Haustieren sicherlich
auch einfach, wie das eben generell auch hier bei Leuten mit Haustieren ist,
einfach eine mentale Geschichte natürlich auch noch ist,
einfach da so eine Nähe zu haben in so einer krassen Situation und für die Katzen
ist natürlich auch gut. Ja.
Also ich denke so, es ist Win-Win. Aber diesen Zusatzaspekt fand ich ganz spannend dann dabei.
Und ja, dann würde ich ganz gerne mal ein bisschen,
jetzt haben wir ja quasi mal geschaut, wie geht es dem Land,
was findet da eigentlich tatsächlich vor Ort statt.
Wie denkst du,
sieht denn jetzt die ukrainische Bevölkerung nach Europa auf ihre potenziellen
Unterstützer oder Nicht-Unterstützer?
Wie hat sich das vielleicht auch verändert?
Auf der einen Seite sicherlich ein Teil Dankbarkeit, dass das überhaupt existiert
auf der anderen Seite natürlich auch viel Frust mit was alles nicht funktioniert und man weiß auch,
dass man in gewisser Hinsicht einen seidenen Faden hängt, der schnell abreißen
kann oder zumindest mögen das vielleicht manche denken,
gerade wenn du da jetzt sozusagen sozusagen aus dem Westen kommst,
wie wird dir da begegnet und was bekommst du davon mit?
Also zum einen glaube ich, wer einem begegnet wird, hängt halt vor allem davon
ab, ob man selber da ist oder nicht.
Und in dem Moment, wo du selber persönlich vor Ort bist, freuen sich immer alle
und sind zufrieden und danken dir, dass du da bist.
Und wenn es dann um Hilfe geht, ja, es ist halt eigentlich genauso,
wie du sagst, zum einen, sie sind froh um alles, was sie bekommen,
weil sie brauchen was, aber sie sehen ja trotzdem, dass sie bei Weib nicht das
bekommen, was sie bräuchten, also was sie mehr bräuchten und vor allem,
dass im Westen noch genug vorhanden wäre oder noch nicht alles ausgegeben ist.
Das ist ja genau die Diskussion, die wir jetzt zur Zeit immer haben.
Und die sagen halt auch, sie verstehen nicht, wie die Leute im Westen die Gefahr
nicht sehen können oder das so ignorieren.
Und der eine hat es so erzählt, der
sagte, stell dir vor, du bist so beim Fußballspiel, du bist der Torwart.
Und dann kommen Leute zu dir und sagen, was machst du nur hier?
Sagst du, ich? Pass hier auf, ne? Ja, warum? Kommt doch gar nichts. Mach doch Pause.
Sagen, so kommen sie sich immer vor und sagen, dir ist schon klar,
dass da ein Fußballspiel läuft, wirst du gleich hier hinschießen.
Nö, die letzten drei Minuten hat keiner geschossen. Was willst du denn?
Und sagten, so in der Art ist die Diskussion immer so, ja Putin greift uns doch
nicht an und was soll das denn und bla und die NATO und die EU wird der nie angreifen, niemals.
Das finde ich auch so geil, wenn mir Leute sagen, was meinst du wäre los,
wenn Putin nur eine Rakete hier rüber schießt. Moment, es waren vier bisher,
ich glaube vier Raketen hat er bisher auf NATO-Gebiet geschossen und zwei Drohnen.
Achso, ne, habe ich nicht mitbekommen. Also ich meine, waren jetzt nicht gezielte
Angriffe, es sind russische Raketen auf NATO-Gebiet runtergekommen.
In Grenznähe, Abwehrraketen etc.
Genau, so Abwehrraketen, bei denen ein war ja die Vermutung,
dass sozusagen die Ukraine die Rakete abgeschossen hat und sie dann beide dabei
über die Grenze nach Polen geflogen sind und da halt dann abgestürzt sind.
Hat sich nie ganz geklärt, aber das würde sagen, war mal so Treffen vom Bild
her und sagt, russische Rakete, NATO-Gebiet, hatten wir, nichts passiert.
Dann vor, ich glaube, das war sogar 2022, die weißrussischen Helikopter,
die über Polen, also so wirklich ein paar Meter über die Grenze und zurückgeflogen sind.
Oder war es Litauen? Ich weiß es nicht mehr. Auf jeden Fall sind die so ein
paar hundert Meter bei die Grenze und zurück.
Hatte auch keine Folgen. Also es gibt so ein paar Dinge, die folgenlos waren.
Und ich glaube, das ist so, also das, was ich mitbekomme von den Ukrainern,
dass die sagen, ihr müsst doch verstehen, dass wir die hier stoppen müssen,
weil sonst geht es weiter und weiter.
Und deswegen, die Diskussion ist da immer ganz simpel, weil ich sage,
ja, verstehe ich, sehe ich genauso, aber ich weiß auch nicht,
wie man es den Leuten in Deutschland vermitteln soll.
Und das alte Problem, also ich meine, wir hier im Studio und alle,
die das hören, denen ist das, glaube ich, so halbwegs klar, da wird das niemand überraschen,
aber so steigt man die U-Bahn und fragt mal irgendwie wahllos Leute,
ob der Krieg in der Ukraine noch läuft oder was da los ist.
Da wundert man sich, was so, sagen wir, in weiten Teilen der Bevölkerung überhaupt
an Nachrichten ankommt oder womit die sich befassen oder ob die das überhaupt interessiert.
Und das ist halt, ja, das ist schwierig sozusagen auf Masse zu vermitteln,
warum das relevant ist und auch mit, warum wir welche Raketen liefern sollten oder nicht.
Ich denke ja all in, schmeiß alles rüber, bis die Russen da raus sind und fertig.
Aber das ist mit dieser Regierung ja nicht zu machen.
Nicht nur mit dieser Regierung, mit vielen Regierungen.
Es ist wirklich eine teilweise wirklich schwierig nachzuvollziehende Grundhaltung.
Also warum macht man nicht sozusagen das maximal Mögliche?
Offensichtlich gehen auch die Einschätzungen darüber, was maximal möglich ist,
auseinander sicherlich, aber viel hat eben auch so mit dieser diffusen Angst
zu tun, dieses Stichwort mit der Eskalation.
Und mich halt immer noch frage, was wollt ihr da eigentlich jetzt noch eskalieren? Ja.
Ich wollte sagen, gehen wir mal die Kriegsverbrechen in Butscha durch. Was soll da kommen?
Also wir haben vermintes Atomkraftwerk sozusagen auf der großen Ebene und wir
haben so die Keller in Butscha auf der persönlichen Ebene.
Was willst du da noch eskalieren?
Ja, das ist ja alles nur in der Ukraine. Ich glaube nicht, dass es in der Debatte
um die Eskalation vor Ort geht, sondern mit Eskalation ist ja gemeint,
könnte ja sein, dass wir jetzt auf einmal die Bösen sind.
Und ich meine, wenn man sich russische Medien anschaut, gut,
das ist halt eh alles ziemlich geskriptet, aber das spricht ja in gewisser Hinsicht
auch eine klare Sprache und nicht nur russisch, sondern….
Da wird ja auch präsentiert, wie sozusagen Russland dann auch das der Gesellschaft so klar macht,
was sie so denken sollen und das ist halt eine anti-westliche Stimmung,
die meiner Meinung nach kaum zu steigern ist.
Ich meine, da wird darüber geredet, Atomraketen auf Berlin zu schmeißen und
irgendwie Finnland wieder einzuholen, das Baltikum sowieso.
Das ist ja alles Russland und Ukraine gibt es ja eigentlich gar nicht.
Der Krieg ist ja eigentlich schon gewonnen und Moldova, naja,
das gehört ja eh zu uns und Rumänien hätten wir auch gerne noch einen Teil davon.
Und ich frage mich halt immer, wie kommt sowas denn eigentlich an?
Ich meine, das einzige Land, was glaube ich da relativ klare Positionen bezieht,
also aus dem EU-Block, ist halt Polen.
Die sagen, geht mir aus der Sonne irgendwie, wir rüsten jetzt hier auf wie nichts
Gutes und die Polen rüsten enorm auf.
Also ich glaube allein was Polen, ich bin mir jetzt bei den Zahlen nicht ganz
so sicher, aber ich habe so einen Vergleich gesehen,
also das was die jetzt sozusagen für die nächsten zwei Jahre an Aufrüstung planen,
5% der Menge ist ungefähr so das, was insgesamt von allen Ländern einschließlich der USA,
der Ukraine zur Verfügung gestellt wurde für diesen Krieg.
Also eine unglaubliche Aufrüstung.
Auch der Punkt mit den Heimars. Ich glaube, Ukraine hat ja elf Heimars oder so bekommen.
Und Polen hat daraufhin 58 bestellt. Also nach dem Motto, wenn du mit elf die
Russen im Schach halten kannst, dann wollen wir mehr.
Ich glaube, die Zahl war sogar noch größer.
Also auf jeden Fall so exorbitante Mengen.
Dreistellig.
Oder vielleicht waren das dann die erste Charge oder sowas.
Ich glaube, es geht eher so in Richtung tausend, die sie haben wollen. Ohne Gewehr jetzt.
Nur da auch ein Punkt. Also ich meine, die Leute interessiert es ja immer meist
erst, wenn es um ihr Portemonnaie geht und sagt, okay, das heißt,
die Amis haben Heimas geliefert, die haben gewirkt und Polen bestellt 1000.
Das heißt, vielleicht hätten wir was liefern können, wovon wir jetzt 1000 verkauft hätten.
Weil ich meine, Javelin sind berühmt geworden dadurch, Enlor so ein bisschen, Heimas, Bayraktar.
Also die TB2, ist auch so lustig. Die TB2 Drohnen kannte ich schon ewig aus
Kurdistan. Da kannte die niemand.
Und dann in der Ukraine wurde bei Raktar berühmt auf einmal. Also so ein paar Sachen.
Gesungen wurde es. Ja genau.
Es gab Plüschtiere davon, es gab Lieder, es gab alles. Oder ich meine der Gepard,
das ist auch so lustig, wie der Gepard hier so in den letzten Jahren schon fast
so abfällig gesehen wurde, so ach komm, wann werden wir das Scheißteil los und
das braucht man doch nie wieder und auf einmal mäht es da eine Drohne nach der anderen runter.
Und alle sagen, war vielleicht nicht ganz so doof.
Ja, das finde ich nur so spannend. Und Polen und ich meine die baltischen Staaten
auch, aber die haben natürlich viel weniger Gewicht und Budget und alles.
Aber zum Beispiel, was die baltischen Staaten noch im Februar 2022 an die Ukraine
geliefert haben, also vor allem diese Manpads, diese schultergestützten Raketenwerfer
und so, die haben quasi ihre Lager leer gemacht.
Und da haben die Ukrainer nachher gesagt, das war ein ganz schöner Unterschied,
die paar hundert Dinger mehr zu haben, also um sozusagen die erste Welle abzufrühstücken
und die sagen, die haben wirklich im Prinzip Garage auf, alles raus und Deutschland sagt, ah,
ich weiß nicht, ich weiß nicht, ob ich dir da einleihen kann und das ist so die Wahrnehmung.
Wir geben euch erstmal Helme.
Genau, ja, wenn die ankommen. Das war ja sieben Wochen lang,
das muss ich ja nochmal erwähnen, habe ich mehr Hilfsgüter in die Ukraine geliefert
als die Bundesregierung.
Ich finde, das ist immer noch die beeindruckendste Zahl.
War aber genauso der Zeitraum dazwischen.
Ja, okay. Aber vielleicht nochmal zurück zu dieser Wahrnehmung der Ukraine von dem Rest.
Also haben wir jetzt sozusagen deren, haben wir das Land jetzt schon so enttäuscht,
dass die uns für immer hassen werden, wenn dieser Krieg dann mal vorbei ist?
Oder ist das tagesformabhängig?
Es ist einfach so ein...
Mir scheint zum einen, dadurch, dass sie selber wissen, dass man nicht immer
mit seiner Regierung so zufrieden ist, sehen die einen deutlichen Unterschied
zwischen Bevölkerung und Regierung.
Und die sehen ja, wie unglaublich deutsche Bevölkerung geholfen hat.
Selbst Leute, die nie mit Krieg zu tun hatten oder nie mit solchen Themen sich
befasst haben, die dann auf einmal zur polnisch-ukrainischen Grenze gefahren
sind am Wochenende, um Leute hin und her zu shutteln.
Und was ich immer noch so krass fand, Flixbus war für mich immer so der Inbegriff
von alles billig und so viel Geld rauswürgen, wie man kann beim Geschäftsmodell.
Und die haben kostenlose Shuttlebusse zur Verfügung gestellt für die Flüchtlinge.
Ich dachte, okay, da war ich echt positiv überrascht. Also so jemand,
dem ich sozusagen dem Klischee nach bösesten Kapitalismus unterstellen würde
und der dann sagt, nee, aber da hört es auf, da helfen wir.
Und das fand ich irre, wie breit diese Allianz war von Leuten,
die kreuz und quer geholfen haben.
Und dann halt auch so diese ganz kleinen Dinge halt wie Wohnungen zur Verfügung
stellen in Berlin am Anfang und sowas.
Also wie das System auch funktioniert hat einfach, fand ich unglaublich.
Also so Couchsurfing im Prinzip für 100.000 Leute oder ich weiß nicht,
wie viele das am Ende genutzt haben.
Und das, glaube ich, vergessen die auch nicht, weil den Klaas,
da haben Individuen geholfen die ganze Zeit.
Und das mit der Regierung, ich glaube, das ist so halb-halb.
Das ist, also es ist ja schon gut, was wir liefern, aber es gibt so zwei Kritikpunkte, die ich habe.
Zum einen habe ich das Gefühl, dass wir nicht so viel liefern, wie wir können.
Und die Bundesregierung, denke ich, die stellt sich da so dämlich an,
weil sie auch nicht mal klarstellen, was geht und was geht nicht,
weil es immer alles geheim und können wir nicht sagen und bla bla.
Aber ich denke, hey, ich bin der Souverän. Ihr vertretet irgendwie, was ich will.
Ich verstehe nicht, warum es immer
so getan wird, als sei ich hier der Bittsteller. Und das andere ist halt,
Ähm, dass die Regierung ja die Wirtschaft massiv daran gehindert hat zu helfen.
Also es gab genug Leute oder genug Unternehmen, die gesagt haben,
wir wollen was liefern und die Regierung hat es nicht gestattet.
Und das, denke ich, ist der Punkt, den kann mir keiner schlüssig erklären,
außer halt diese Russland-geile Russland-Reue oder dieses, oh nein,
nicht, dass die uns dann irgendwie böse finden.
Aber warum sagt man der Wirtschaft nicht, hey generell, ihr dürft alles in die
Ukraine liefern, was ihr irgendwie liefern könnt, auf die Tore.
Weil da wäre ich gespannt, was die alle noch liefern würden.
Und das dürfen sie nicht? Nee, die ganz vielen nicht. Rheinmetall hatte sich
doch böse aufgeregt, dass sie nicht einfach Produktion rüberschmeißen können.
Das fand ich auch eben so spannend. Die großen Rüstungskonzerne in Deutschland,
oder das ist ja in jedem Land so, die haben ja üblicherweise sehr,
sehr gute Verbindungen zu einer Regierung.
Und sind auch sozusagen ein bisschen regierungstreu oder der positiv eingestellt
oder wie man es nennen will. Also man kennt sich und man will sich nicht ärgern.
Und als dann aber irgendwann die großen Rüstungskonzerne vor die Presse gegangen
sind und gesagt haben, mit dieser Einstellung der Regierung sind wir jetzt aber
nicht zufrieden, weil wir würden gerne mehr liefern.
Da habe ich gedacht, da muss aber die Hütte brennen, dass die sozusagen ihren
Hauptauftraggeber so vorführen oder öffentlich über den meckern.
Ich kann mich nicht erinnern, dass ich das schon mal erlebt hatte,
dass also KfW oder Rheinmetall öffentlich sagen, das finde ich scheiße oder
das finde ich nicht gut, ich würde hier gern mehr machen.
Und da habe ich auch gedacht, wie viel ist da schon intern gelaufen,
bis die wirklich mal nach außen gehen.
Das ist halt, ja, das sind so die Dinge, die könnte man ja einfach ändern.
Also es gibt zum Beispiel eine Allgemeinverfügung, dass man schusssichere Westen
und Helme in die Ukraine ohne weitere Anmeldung exportieren kann.
Also man muss die Mengen melden, aber man muss nicht eine einzelne Exporterlaubnis
holen, sondern es gibt eine allgemeine Exporterlaubnis. Aber sowas in der Art
machen, sagen, alles, alles was du lieferst, also solange der Abnehmer es legal
erwerben darf, also an die Armee oder so, hau raus.
Dann wäre ich gespannt, was dann durchgehen würde.
Tatsächlich ist ja die Kooperation dieser Rüstungsunternehmen mit der Ukraine
auch sehr weitreichend.
Also Trompet Granmetall baut jetzt sogar ein Werk in der Ukraine als Joint Venture.
Keine Ahnung, welche Rechtsform das jetzt hat oder vielleicht ist es auch gar nicht mal nur ein Werk.
Also es geht ja um verschiedenste Sachen. Es geht um Reparaturzentren für Leopard.
Leopard, würde mich auch nicht wundern, wenn die irgendwann anfangen,
Leoparden zu bauen und ich glaube, es ist sogar im Gespräch,
diesen neuen Panzer, was heißt der von Rheinmetall?
KfW, glaube ich, ja.
Den zu produzieren, wie heißt dieses Teil nochmal, weißt du das?
Der Nachfolger von der Kuhle. Der Kuhle, das Superteil und neue Haubitze und
so weiter ist ja auch einiges in der Produktionspipeline gewesen,
was jetzt sozusagen rechtzeitig rauskommt.
Also die deutsche Rüstungsindustrie kann jetzt hier auch wirklich eine große
Rolle spielen und man wundert sich natürlich dann immer wenn das in irgendeiner Form beschränkt wird.
Weiter mal vielleicht mal den Blick auf ganz Europa.
So das Verhältnis der Ukraine, also zu Polen denke ich mal ist das spätestens
jetzt auch nach dem Regierungswechsel das dürfte wahrscheinlich,
also sicherlich kein vollständig ungetrübtes Verhältnis sein,
wie das nun mal so ist, weil es gibt natürlich durch die Nähe auch ein paar Konflikte.
Es gab da diesen Streik der Traka an der Grenze, die die Grenze blockiert haben.
Es gab Ich habe Heckmeck so mit irgendwie dem freien Import von Getreide und
so weiter, weil das natürlich auch alles immer lokale Auswirkungen hat und dann
hast du auf einmal Druck von deinen eigenen Bauern.
Das kann man irgendwie alles verstehen, aber grundsätzlich steht glaube ich
Polen fest an der Seite der Ukraine und ist sicherlich der verlässlichste Nachbar.
Aber dann wiederum gibt es aber dann eben solche Problemfälle wie Ungarn,
die also einfach eine Russlandnähe haben, wo man sich wirklich fragt,
wie das eigentlich sein kann.
Also ein Land, was selber von Russland jahrzehntelang besetzt, unterdrückt wurde.
Und was in der NATO ist, was in der EU ist, also jegliche westliche Verankerung hat,
die man irgendwie nur haben kann, aber trotzdem dort täglich eine Propaganda
gefahren wird, die auch anti-ukrainisch ist.
Ich war jetzt selber ein paar Tage da, hab das nur so am Rande mitbekommen,
hab mich mit einem Taxifahrer unterhalten, um einfach zu verstehen, wie die das so sehen.
Und es hat nicht lange gedauert, bis sozusagen in der Liste seiner Skepsispunkte
so klare russische Propaganda-Talking-Points aufkamen.
Ja, die foltern ja die Russen auf der Krim und so eine Geschichte,
wo ich mir nur denke, so fängst du jetzt an dagegen zu argumentieren oder speicherst
jetzt diese Information einfach mal ab. Und.
Bei dem Argument sage ich jedes Mal, also abgesehen davon, dass es nicht stimmt,
aber wenn es stimmen würde, wenn du russische Soldaten in der Ukraine folterst,
würde ich sagen, dann mach dich doch nicht auf den Weg in ein Land,
was dich foltert, dann bleib doch zu Hause.
Das wäre mein Top-Tipp an den russischen Soldaten. Ja.
An den russischen Soldaten. In dem Fall war es ja einfach ein ungarischer Taxifahrer,
der wollte da jetzt sicherlich nicht hin. Nee.
Nur sein Argument halt.
Ja, stimmt schon. Nur das...
Also das ist mir vollkommen unklar. Dann kamen aber auch schnell solche Sachen
auf wie, ja es gibt ja dann auch so eine ungarische Minderheit im Westen der Ukraine.
Ja die gibt es, die ist nicht besonders groß und die ist ja auch irgendwie unterdrückt
worden und was nicht alles, was sicherlich irgendwann mal so war.
Zu Sowjetzeiten.
Also die Zustimmung für dieses 50 Milliarden Paket durch Ungarn ist jetzt glaube
ich durch, weil Ungarn im Prinzip mit Stimmenentzug gedroht wurde und das ist
dann halt so ein Punkt, wo sie dann auch nicht mehr machen.
Ich denke, mit Ungarn das Problem, also gab es ja schon bevor die Invasion losging,
also wie lange das dauert, bis die EU da mal wirklich sozusagen aus dem Knick kommt,
das denke ich, das ist immer so traurig, wenn so sagen wir in irgendeiner Form
politische Spielverderber auftreten, wo man dann erst merkt,
wie kaputt so Systeme sind und wie die gar nicht richtig reagieren können.
Also wie in der EU, ich weiß jetzt gar nicht, wie viele Jahre das mit Ungarn
so geht, also mit so verschiedenen BKK, genau.
Und so richtig hat man sie also sozusagen noch nicht im Griff,
sondern es ist halt, also sie können dauernd weiter so ein Blödsinn machen und
sie kriegen weiterhin ihre EU-Ausgleichszahlung und dann geht es mal hin und
her, aber das denke ich, wie simpel man halt so eine ganze EU sabotieren kann,
das zeigen die leider beeindruckend.
Ähnlicher Problemfall scheint jetzt die Slowakei zu sein, noch nicht ganz so
schlimm wie Ungarn und ich glaube, die kriegt man auch noch ein bisschen besser
in den Griff gerade, weil viel von dem Widerstand, der jetzt hochkam,
nachdem der FIKO wieder Ministerpräsident wurde,
jetzt wohl auch so ein bisschen wieder zurückgedreht werden konnte.
Aber mal abgesehen jetzt davon,
wie schätzt du generell die Unterstützungsbereitschaft Europas so ein?
Also die Negativbeispiele haben wir jetzt genannt.
Deutschland ist halt irgendwo so im Mittelfeld, hat viel,
kann viel, liefert auch viel, macht halt viel im Bereich von,
ja ihr habt ja Geld, damit ihr euren Staat stützen könnt, humanitäre Hilfe und
so weiter, wo sie sich ja immer schon so ein bisschen den Bauch in die Sonne gehalten haben für,
nur eben, dass halt militärisch auch noch sehr viel mehr passieren könnte.
Dann gibt es halt kleine Länder wie Dänemark und Niederlande,
die halt sehr viel machen, die jetzt die F-16 liefern und da unter Umständen
auch kriegsentscheidende Punkte setzen.
Aber wir sprechen halt hier wirklich nicht mit einer Sprache. Nee.
Und mir scheint also im Großen und Ganzen sehen die das alles positiv,
weil sie halt wissen, ohne diese ganzen Hilfen wären sie halt,
also dann wäre Kiew wirklich massiv in Gefahr gewesen.
Aber sozusagen, mir scheint, die sehen die Hilfen eher so in Summe.
Also nicht die einzelnen Länder, sondern sie sagen, alles insgesamt, was kommt, ist gut.
Und sie nehmen halt wahr, dass einzelne Länder besonders schlecht sind.
Aber sagen wir mal, auch die EU-Hilfen und UK und USA und so,
mir scheint, dass das häufiger als ein so ein Block auch gesehen wird.
Also bei den meisten Leuten einfach nur sagen, es kommt viel Hilfe,
das ist gut, das hilft uns.
Ich denke halt speziell zu den Niederlanden, die haben halt nicht vergessen,
dass MH17 da abgeschossen wurde, was also hier ja immer schon so in Vergessenheit
geraten ist, aber du vergisst den halt nicht so schnell, der in einem eh schon kleinen Land,
also Bayern sich ihrer aber halt mit vielen Niederländern besetzt,
dass der runtergeholt wurde.
Stimmt. Das ist ein Punkt, genau. Und Skandinavien, denke ich mal,
verhält sich generell auch anders.
Wird jetzt auch nochmal spannend sein zu sehen, wenn dann jetzt der Widerstand
Ungarns und der Türkei final aufgebrochen wurde mit dem NATO-Beitritt Schwedens,
was ja auch eine Phase ist, dass das so lange dauert.
Noch zu Skandinavien auch, die haben ja bei EMA also waren relativ stark so
im Sinne von ihrem Nationalstolz oder so, unser Land und uns greift hier keiner
an und so, also da schien mir, dass das,
ja stärker ist als in anderen EU-Ländern, dieses deswegen auch eigene Kampfjets
entwickeln, also selbst als kleine Länder, so eigene Rüstungsindustrie,
also dieses sich selber verteidigen können und so, das hatte da zumindest schien
mir mal einen anderen Stellenwert noch als bei uns.
Also bei uns ist ja auch, ich meine, Rüstungsindustrie ist bei uns auch einfach
großer Arbeitgeber und Exportprodukt und so, aber ja nicht in erster,
also ich meine, wir haben, meine ich, bei der Bundeswehr 250 oder 300 Panzer,
also Main Battle Tanks zur Zeit, die aktiv verfügbar sind.
Dafür bräuchtest du keine Rüstungsindustrie, also für sozusagen die paar Panzer.
Während also Finnland und Schweden auch, die hatten ja ab und zu diese Sachen
mit russischen U-Booten die da waren oder nicht waren und diese verschiedenen Fälle,
dass die da auch nicht gesagt haben, lass mal drüber verhandeln,
sondern die haben gesagt ist das jetzt euer U-Boot? Nein?
Gut, dann werfen wir jetzt Semin und gucken was es ist also die hatten da ja
schon so andere Gangarten immer wieder also nicht im Sinne von schlimm nationalistisch
oder so, aber so im Sinne von,
dass sie ein anderes Gefühl für haben, für das ist Umsatz und da kommt keiner ran.
Ja, so eine eigene Autonomie auch sicherstellen, auch im Gegensatz zum Mitteleuropa etc.
Also ich glaube, Skandinavien hat sich da schon immer sehr gut gefallen.
Zurecht auch, ähnliches gilt ja auch für Finnland, die ja noch eine sehr viel
klarere Bedrohung haben.
Also Russland hat ja Finnland dann auch auch überfallen, zu dem Zweiten Weltkrieg,
große Gebiete auch sich einverleibt, etc. Das haben die auch nicht vergessen.
Und die Wehrhaftigkeit der finnischen Bevölkerung, glaube ich,
ist übertrifft, glaube ich,
Alles, was man sonst so in Europa hat, gemessen an wie viele Leute da theoretisch
in der Reserve sind, wie viele Bunker es gibt, wie viel.
Auch die Ausbildung. Also ich habe mal mit finnischen Soldaten zu tun gehabt und ich hatte halt das,
also ich meine, es ist wieder so, ich habe nur ein paar von getroffen,
aber die waren halt also richtig höflich, gut gebildet und auch richtig gut
ausgerüstet und ausgebildet.
Also man merkte, es hatte, also nicht so, dass man sagte, ja komm,
ich mach hier mal meine zwei Wochen, sondern so, ich hatte das Gefühl,
sie wollen wirklich wissen, wie es geht, wenn der Krieg kommt.
Also, dass sie es wirklich ernst genommen haben, diese Aufgabe und nicht so
9 to 5 Job und dann gehe ich saufen oder sowas. Also so mit einer ziemlichen
Ernsthaftigkeit dahinter.
Ich denke, das ist ja so ungefähr 100 Jahre her, hatten die ja die große,
also mehrere Probleme dann so, also vor 80 bis 100 Jahren erst,
ja nicht nur mit russischen, also Russland damals erst, sondern dann ja auch
Deutschland, also Nazi-Deutschland.
So ich denke, okay, die sozusagen die letzten Kriege in der Geschichte waren
zwei Großmächte haben sie angegriffen, nacheinander.
Und dann kann ich mir auch vorstellen, dass sich sozusagen historisch das Meer
verfestigt mit, okay, wir müssen selber auf uns achten können und nicht so sehr
auf Bündnis ausgelegt halt oder nur als sozusagen als zweite Schutzmaßnahme.
Aber ja, was ich dann immer noch so komisch finde, die Ostsee,
dass da ja immer noch die russischen Spionageschiffe hin und her tuckern die
ganze Zeit und dann heißt, ja, aber es gibt internationale Verträge und deswegen
dürfen wir nichts machen.
Ich denke echt, steht in internationalen Verträgen auch, dass man im Butscher
im Keller Leute zu Tode folgern darf?
Ich verstehe die Messlatte nicht, dass man sagt, ja die begehen am Tag so viel
Kriegsverbrechen, dass sie niemandem erzählen kann, aber ich kann doch dem Boot
nicht sagen, es darf hier nicht uns ausspionieren.
Also das denke ich, da würde mich mal interessieren, was die für Bauchmuskeln
in Russland haben vom Lachen über wie doof die EU ist, dass die sich so einen
Scheiß gefallen lässt den ganzen Tag lang.
Ja, man hat manchmal so ein bisschen den Eindruck, dass einfach der Respekt
vor Russland einfach alles übersteigt, was in dieser Situation noch angemessen ist. Und vielleicht...
Wird es natürlich auch ein Kristallisationspunkt werden für die EU?
In gewisser Hinsicht ist es ja, was die NATO betrifft, hat das ja schon stattgefunden.
EU ist glaube ich nochmal ein bisschen anders. Da wird jetzt auch viel davon
abhängen, wie sehr mit der Mitgliedschaft der potenziellen der Ukraine in der
EU umgegangen wird weiterhin.
Jetzt hat man es natürlich erstmal in so einen symbolischen Bereich reingetragen
mit, ja ihr seid jetzt offiziell auf diesem Kandidatenpfad und damit es nicht
so auffällt, nimmt man Moldawien halt auch gleich noch mit.
Was jetzt sicherlich nicht so hoch auf der Liste stand,
obwohl ich mich ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen wundere, weil wenn man sich klar macht,
was für ein reiches Land eigentlich diese Region Moldawien und Ukraine ist,
also Agrarmäßig, Militärindustrie,
Technologie, also Software. Luftwehr.
Wir könnten die Ukraine in die EU einnehmen und dann programmieren die uns mal irgendwie die Apps.
Eine Alarm-App, die funktioniert.
Ja, Alarm-App, einfach mal alles irgendwie so.
Nur ich meine, es scheitert ja, es scheitert an dieser Alarm-App,
wo so jeder sagt, die kannst du mit einem HTTP-Request schreiben, diese App.
Naja.
Du weißt ja.
Wie das ist.
Ja, nicht auszuhalten.
Und jetzt müssen wir aber noch über einen anderen Aspekt sprechen, nämlich die USA.
Die haben wir bisher ein bisschen rausgelassen. Vielleicht auch nochmal da erst
der Blick der Ukraine auf die USA.
Also Europa hatten wir ja jetzt schon. Ich glaube, da verhält es sich irgendwie ähnlich. Ähnlich.
Wobei natürlich der Unterschied ist und vielleicht nehmen wir auch mal UK hier mit rein.
Letzten Endes ja auch die beiden Länder, die damals bei dem Vertrag von Budapester
Memorandum quasi sich als Schutzmächte angemeldet haben.
Haben gesagt haben, ja hier die Einigung mit Russland, also wo ja im Prinzip
drin stand, wir greifen euch nicht an und eure Grenzen sind...
Die Ukraine gibt die Atomwaffen ab, das war ja die Grundlage.
Genau, und die Ukraine gibt die Atomwaffen ab und dafür greift ihr das Land
nicht an und akzeptiert diese Grenzen, was sie dann halt nicht getan haben.
Und da stand halt drin, USA und UK...
Sorgen dafür, dass das stattfindet oder nicht so ganz klar.
Das ist so ein Detail. Also das sind ja bilaterale Verträge jeweils am Ende
geworden und die verschiedenen Schutzmächte sagen, dass sie die Ukraine im Falle
eines nuklearen Angriffs oder einer nuklearen Bedrohung schützen.
Darauf zieht man sich jetzt ja mal zurück. Das heißt ja, sorry,
da ist noch keine Atombombe geworfen.
Formal gilt das nicht.
Wenn es jetzt heißt, ja da sind doch keine US-Soldaten im Land,
doch klar, seit zehn Jahren.
Das ist ein öffentliches, bekanntes Mandat und so, das ist alles nicht geheim.
Das merkt man ganz massiv, also wenn man sich sozusagen ein bisschen genauer
die Videos anguckt von wie die ukrainische Armee agiert bei der Übernahme der Krim.
Jetzt mal böse gesagt, sah das aus wie so ein Haufen Minions,
die sich nicht sicher sind, was sie jetzt tun, wenn russische Spezialeinheiten kommen.
Und wenn man dann die Aufnahmen sieht von den letzten zwei Jahren,
wenn man so ein bisschen Blick führt, sagt man, die sind von den Amis ausgebildet und die von den Briten.
Also das siehst du so an den Vorgehensweisen schon, aber dass das quasi 90 Prozent
auch so durchgezogen wird mit ein paar Anpassungen.
Und hat ja offensichtlich auch viel gebracht, das Training.
Also zum einen das Training der Leute und zum anderen dann die Waffen,
die sie noch dazu bekommen haben und die Ausrüstung.
Und deswegen scheint mir gerade der Blick, also Amis und Briten sind ja eh,
muss man sagen, fast immer zusammen irgendwo.
Also egal welches Kriegsgebiet und auch die Basen teilen die sich ja oft.
Also im Prinzip kommen die glaube ich immer im Doppelpack. Ich kann mich an
nicht viel erinnern, wo nur einer von beiden da war so in den letzten Jahren.
Feiglandkrieg vielleicht.
Ja gut, aber das war ja sozusagen eine interne Angelegenheit,
wenn man es jetzt mal böse sieht.
Aber auch dazu nur, ich denke das ist so lustig, während einer der,
ich glaube die größte Marineübung, die die Briten hatten, sich den Moment auszusuchen,
um einen Krieg anzufangen, war auch ein schlechtes Timing irgendwie.
Also die saßen ja alle auf den Schiffen und waren sozusagen abfahrbereit.
So, aber deswegen in der Ukraine habe ich das Gefühl, dass, also erstmal,
dass die zehn Jahre Training reingesteckt haben, hat da niemand vergessen und
halt diese Kolonnen von Lastern mit den Javelin-Panzerabwehrwaffen und eben
HIMARS, also zwei ganz relevante Dinge, die da ja kamen von,
und dann die NLAW, die anderen Panzerabwehrwaffen, also Briten und Amis,
die waren wirklich kriegsentscheidend.
Und auch diese ganze Luftraumüberwachung, die Kampfjets,
maßgeblich sind es ja Briten und Amerikaner, die die halbe EU-Außengrenze die
ganze Zeit überwachen und auch das Schwarze Meer, wenn die da durchfliegen.
Und es sind ihre Kampfjets, die das im Großen und Ganzen schützen auch.
Das ist ja nicht, dass die Bundeswehr jetzt sozusagen die großen Macher im Schwarzen
Meer sind, sondern die Amis sind federführend, obwohl es bei uns vor der Tür
ist oder zum Teil sind dann die NATO Drohnen bei, die aus Italien und so starten.
Aber sagen wir mal, wenn man aus dieser gesamten Rechnung Ukraine kriegt,
sagen wir mal, wir würden Italien rausnehmen.
Ich glaube, dann würde er nicht so wesentlich anders laufen.
Nimmt man aus der ganzen Rechnung aber die USA raus, dann wäre der Krieg anders gelaufen.
Und das ist den Leuten in der Ukraine ganz klar, was da auch permanent den ganzen
Tag ja an Hilfe kommt, an Aufklärung von Satelliten, von Flugzeugen,
von allem, was die da rumfahren haben.
Also ohne das, das sind ja sozusagen die Augen und Ohren der Ukraine die ganze Zeit, Tag und Nacht.
Umso größer dürfte die Angst sein, wenn man sich die Wirren anschaut,
die die amerikanische Politik jetzt wieder durchmacht.
Wahlen anstehen, es derzeit so aussieht, als ob die Republikaner sich auf niemand
anderen wirklich einigen können als Donald Trump.
Es ist noch vollkommen unklar, ob die amerikanische Justiz in der Lage sein
wird, ihn noch rechtzeitig in den Knast zu bekommen.
Er hat ja genug Anklagen an den Hacken und bisher eigentlich auch alles verloren,
aber es ist halt wieder so eine Zuspitzung bis hin zum Supreme Court,
wo es halt theoretisch noch sein kann, dass von ihm bestellte Richter sagen,
ach ja nö, das war schon alles so ganz in Ordnung und dann ist halt wirklich Staatskrise angesagt.
Also wissen wir alles nicht, aber weil der Teil des Kongresses,
des Haus derzeit eben von den Republikanern dominiert wird und nach diesen ganzen Machtkämpfen,
die dort zuletzt abgelaufen sind rund um diese Sprecherposition jetzt so ein
totaler Magaschilder am Start ist und derzeit einfach alles blockiert,
werden ja keine weiteren Gelder freigegeben.
Das heißt, es könnte eben sein, dass im allerschlimmsten Fall diese Blockade
noch monatelang weitergetrieben wird,
einfach weil aus der Sicht der Republikaner, ja was interessiert mich die Ukraine und Russland,
wichtig ist, dass wir jetzt hier wieder den Präsidenten stellen und wenn wir
hier genug Krisen erzeugen, dann können wir uns ja so platzieren,
dass wir dann die Krisen dann lösen, wenn wir dann mal die Macht haben.
Das ist dieser Zynismus, der da gerade vorherrscht und das ist ja auch etwas,
was nicht nur die Ukraine beunruhigen sollte, sondern natürlich eigentlich auch
die gesamte EU und Deutschland und so weiter.
Weil es ja auch bedeuten kann, dass im allerschlimmsten Fall,
man mag es sich gar nicht vorstellen, aber würde jetzt tatsächlich die USA sozusagen
sich komplett zurückziehen und sagen, mach doch was ihr wollt.
Was ich mir tatsächlich wirklich nicht wirklich vorstellen kann,
aber es ist so ein Szenario, was da ist, das würde ja auch bedeuten,
dass die EU sich eigentlich komplett neu aufstellen muss. Europa sich komplett neu aufstellen muss.
Wenn man das mal auf die Spitze treiben will, ich glaube auch nicht,
dass das passiert, aber was ja immer wieder so als Drohung in den Raum geworfen
wurde, die USA könnten ja aus der NATO austreten.
Wie seit ich halte es für unrealistisch, aber man sollte mal darüber nachdenken,
was dann wäre. Das ist halt auch wieder dieser Punkt.
Also alleine diese Überwachung vom Schwarzen Meer.
Ich denke, eigentlich müssten doch die verschiedenen Armeen in der EU sagen,
hey, danke, Amis und Briten, dass ihr das macht, aber wir übernehmen jetzt.
Wir brauchen euch nicht, weil wir machen das. Und vielen, vielen Dank,
dass ihr bisher geholfen habt.
Ich glaube nicht, dass die Amis sich drum kloppen, ihr Geld da zu verbrennen.
Also es ist ja immer eine Kosten-Nutzen-Rechnung für die, klar und so.
Aber aus Amisicht kann man sagen, ja, das ist auf der anderen Seite der Welt.
Also umgekehrt, die Bundeswehr kümmert sich doch auch nicht in Mittelamerika
um die Terroristen, die da sind zum Beispiel.
Wir sagen nicht, das ist unsere Aufgabe, jetzt in Kolumbien irgendwie die Rebellen zu stoppen oder so.
Würde man ja hier auch sagen, sorry, ich weiß nicht mal, wie die Gruppe heißt
und was habe ich denn damit zu tun?
Also in Mali haben wir das probiert, nicht mit besonders viel Erfolg und das
verfängt ja hier auch nicht so.
Ja genau und das war schon weit genug weg, aber Mali ist noch so auf dem Globus
auf der gleichen Seite sozusagen, wenn du den drehst.
Für den Rest musst du ja schon weiter drehen. Ja das stimmt.
Und das denke ich sozusagen aus Ami-Sicht, dass die sagen, also jetzt so ein
durchschnittlicher Mensch, der in Ami-Land lebt, dass der sagt,
was habe ich mit der Ukraine zu tun, kann ich in gewissem Maß nachvollziehen,
weil ja du hast nichts mit denen zu tun. Und wenn die Moldawien übernehmen, immer noch nicht.
Und wenn die Deutschland übernehmen, immer noch nicht. Aber...
Wir schon. Und das finde ich halt das Schlimme daran, wir haben doch eine EU,
damit wir irgendwie irgendetwas tun.
Also es ging ja nicht darum, dass wir ohne Pass über die Grenze können.
Es war jetzt nicht die Touristenunion oder sowas die Idee dahinter.
Das hatten wir schon mit, also was auch viele ja nicht verstehen,
das ist Schengen, das ist nicht die EU. Das sind ja auch nochmal verschiedene Sachen.
So und deswegen denke ich, uns und Frankreich geht es ja so federführend an,
weil wir die großen Player hier sind.
Polen, weil sie inzwischen echt wirtschaftlich stark sind und die direkten Nachbarn
und irgendwie die zusammen müssten schützen. Die Briten haben wir nicht mehr in der EU.
Schade drum, aber gerade jetzt wären die sehr hilfreich, weil die sind extrem
erfahren mit wirklich Kriegen auf großer Skala.
Und mit Diplomatie. Ja.
Genau, also Krieg oder Diplomatie, sag es mir in Dollar, ist so der alte Spruch.
Ja, aber die, sozusagen das, was sie in diesem Bereich an Erfahrung haben,
ich habe halt nicht das Gefühl,
dass wir das ersetzen können oder also wenn es wirklich hart auf hart kommt
und jetzt speziell mit Scholz, ich weiß nicht, ich weiß nicht.
Im Prinzip müssten doch jetzt die EU-Staaten sagen, alles, was die Amis bisher
machen, übernehmen wir, weil das ist unser Backyard hier, unser Hinterhof sozusagen,
die Ukraine und wir wollen die ja in die EU holen.
Die USA sagt nicht, wir wollen die als US-Bundesstaat, sondern wir wollen die
potenziell, wenn die mal ihre Probleme gefixt haben, aber in der EU haben,
ja dann müssten wir doch jetzt alles übernehmen und mal zeigen,
dass wir auf der Welt wirklich eine richtig große Rolle spielen und nicht immer
wir sind die Zweitbesten.
Wo ich denke, toll, kennst du irgendwie einen Formel-1-Rennfahrer,
der sagt, ich hole dieses Jahr
den zweiten Platz, da freue ich mich so richtig drauf oder den dritten.
Nee, also sozusagen so spielst du nicht mit, wenn du oben mitspielen willst.
Und das, was wir jetzt immer machen ist, ja wir müssen erst die USA fragen,
ob wir die Raketen liefern können.
Und wir müssen erst, wo ich denke, sag mal, sind wir, also, dann lass uns doch
die Regierung hier kippen und wir fragen immer beiden, was wir tun und lassen
dürfen, aber immer dieses, nee, wir müssen uns erst mit den anderen abstimmen.
Ich denke, dafür brauche ich keine Regierung wählen, dass ihr mal jemand anderen
fragen müsst, was wir jetzt machen. Das ist irgendwie nicht meine Idee.
Ja vor allem, ich meine, ich habe ja überhaupt nichts dagegen, dass man sich abstimmt.
Aber ich glaube, wenn jetzt Deutschland sagen würde, wir liefern jetzt mal die
Taurus Missiles direkt und machen nicht hier wieder so einen bekloppten Ringtausch-Quatsch,
dann würde die USA sagen, super.
Ja, die würden nicht sagen, das finden wir jetzt doof.
Ihr könnt doch nicht einfach was liefern, bevor wir was geliefert haben. Genau.
Und ihr könnt doch nicht, wir wollten Steuern ausgeben. Wir wollten uns unbeliebt machen.
Ja.
Das ist, also das denke ich halt auch, das ist für die Amis ist es weit weg
und da kann man nur froh sein, dass sie bisher so drauf achten,
aber wenn die aus der Nummer raus sind, dann wird es düster, ne?
Dann wird es wirklich düster.
UK ist da offensichtlich einen Schritt weiter.
Ich habe es jetzt ehrlich gesagt gar nicht so genau verfolgt,
aber es gab jetzt ein Abkommen, eine Vereinbarung zwischen der Ukraine und UK,
hier für weitere Sicherheit zu garantieren.
Kannst du da mal Licht drauf schütten? Ich habe es noch nicht so ganz verstanden,
inwiefern das jetzt nur ein Lippenbekenntnis ist oder tatsächlich eine Verschärfung.
Aber generell habe ich so den Eindruck, wird der Ukraine-Konflikt in London sehr ernst genommen.
Ja und aus verschiedenen Gründen. Ein Teil dieses neuen Deals,
ich weiß nicht, ob es direkt im Deal drin steht oder ob es so ein Nebenarm oder
wie man sagen will davon ist halt,
dass die Briten halt Waffen liefern, aber halt auf Rechnung.
Also die kommt dann auf den Stapel, also nicht, dass man sagt,
aus gutem Willen gibt es Weihnachtsgeschenke, sondern so wie wenn man die Kreditlinie einfach erhöht.
Zum einen hat man dann Interesse, dass es der Ukraine irgendwann besser geht
und dass sie gewinnen, weil man will sein Geld zurück.
Aber ich meine, die Briten brauchen zur Zeit auch jeden Pfund inzwischen ja
wieder, den sie da halt haben können.
Das stimmt, im Außenhandel läuft es gerade nicht so gut.
Nee. Und sozusagen, wenn du jetzt auf Vorrat produzierst und gehst von aus,
dass du in zehn Jahren oder so die Raten kriegst.
Irgendjemand wird ausrechnen, ob es ein guter Deal ist oder nicht.
Und das andere ist, was es hieß, was da mit…,
dranhängt oder mit irgendwie mit verbunden ist, ist eben auch so Sachen wie,
Handelsoptionen mit der Ukraine und auch Getreide und Know-how-Transfer.
Also nicht mal, dass es jetzt einfach darum geht, der Ukraine helfen als guter
Mensch, sondern ich meine, schreien gerade nicht alle hier, wenn die Briten
irgendwelche neuen Verträge mit Außenhandel oder sonst was machen wollen.
Und jetzt können sie was bringen, was die Ukraine braucht und in Zukunft kann
man von ausgehen, dass Die Ukraine genug hat.
Was man gebrauchen könnte.
Genau, also in welcher Form auch immer und dass es da also vor allem so um die Zukunft geht.
Also wir helfen euch jetzt aus der Scheiße und dann machen wir hier sowas wie
die Anti-EU, um es mal ganz blöde zu sagen oder sowas.
Also die beiden Outcasts sozusagen halten da zusammen.
Und das macht ja aus ukrainischer Sicht auch Sinn. Also jeden Deal nehmen im
Moment, den man kriegen kann.
Also selbst wenn die Ukraine in die EU geht, UK muss ja ohnehin mit jedem europäischen
Land einzelne Verträge schließen, eben weil die EU-Verträge nicht automatisch gelten.
Von daher mag das sicherlich nochmal so ein Aspekt sein.
Aber ich habe auch das Gefühl, dass es jenseits dieser wirtschaftlichen Überlegungen
in London auch irgendwie einen Nerv trifft, dieser Konflikt auf eine Art und
Weise, wie das in Deutschland einfach noch nicht stattgefunden hat.
Ja und mir scheint auch sozusagen in den USA,
ich erinnere mich wie in so 80er und 90er Jahre vor allem,
also in so Comedy-Filmen immer wieder es so Gags gab auf Kosten von Kommunisten
oder so die Kommunisten-Hasser oder im Film Cannonball Run fahren sie durch
so ein Dorf und da steht so ein, hängt an so einem Haus so ein Werbeplakat,
wählt den Sheriff wieder den Joe Kill a Commie Warner oder sowas.
Also so, dass es immer so Gags gab, so wir sind gegen die Kommunisten und so,
aber es war halt schon zu so einer Fraßverkommenheit zu so einem Gag.
Und ich glaube, alle diese Leute, die immer gesagt haben,
also ich meine, Russland wird ja immer noch als die Kommunisten von denen gesehen,
das hat sich jetzt ja nicht maßgeblich so geändert in der simplen Welt,
dass die jetzt sagen können, ich hatte Recht, ich hatte 50 Jahre lang Recht
und ich hatte immer Recht und jetzt,
jetzt kommt meine Zeit zu glänzen.
Also ich glaube, das ist ein Aspekt, von dem die länger dabei sind.
Dann eben, den anderen ist klar, also immer wenn so ein großer Krieg kommt,
es gibt keinen Gewinner.
Also sagen wir, wenn Russland jetzt tatsächlich weitergehen würde,
es gibt kein Szenario, was für UK gut wäre.
Ja, also es ist ja nicht gut, wenn Ukraine übernommen wird, nicht gut,
wenn Polen übernommen wird, also es gibt nichts, wo sie sagen,
ey, da haben wir einen Vorteil von und zum anderen ja auch noch einen klaren
Nachteil, was ja auch nicht immer das gleiche ist,
aber dass sie da Probleme haben könnten, auch klar.
Und deswegen, ich glaube, zum einen sozusagen Geschichte und zum anderen auch,
die waren in so vielen Kriegen und so was oder in so Konflikten viel stärker involviert.
Also ich meine, wir hatten auch Bundeswehr in Afghanistan, wir hatten die in
Mali, wir hatten die in Kurdistan und so, aber halt immer, eigentlich immer
eine kleinere Rolle und auch viel weniger diese direkten Kampfeinsätze.
Ich habe das Gefühl, dass das bei den Briten halt auch einen Unterschied macht,
dass die wissen, was wirklich ein Krieg dann bedeutet, also wenn der hier rüber
rollt oder jetzt in der Ukraine ist.
Und in Deutschland habe ich halt nicht das Gefühl, dass Leute einen Bezug zu
Krieg haben, was ja eigentlich sehr schön ist, wenn man sagt,
das ist so lange her, das weiß keiner mehr.
Ja, es fiel mir nur wieder auf, als Silvester die Leute sagten,
boah, wie Krieg und so und dann hatte ich irgendwann auf Twitter geschrieben,
also ich verstehe total, dass man das Geballer blöd findet und so,
aber ganz ehrlich, es ist halt nicht wie Krieg, also da sind schon noch Unterschiede.
Was mir da entgegenschlug von Leuten mit, das ist genau so und das macht gar
keinen, also so, die der festen Überzeugung waren, wenn Böller fliegt,
das ist wie Krieg. Und das weiß ich.
Dachte, okay, die Realität ist ganz woanders von denen und von mir.
Und ich glaube, bei den Briten ist das Thema, also die können sich besser vorstellen,
was das heißt, wenn der Konflikt rüberschwappt.
Schwappt, während hier ich nicht das Gefühl habe, dass Leute das,
also erstmal, dass die Leute hier nicht glauben, dass das passiert,
auch wenn es heißt, das ist so weit weg, ich denke, das ist.
Also, das ist ungefähr so weit weg wie Barcelona, um es mal so zu sagen,
so der Kriegsschauplatz und Barcelona sieht man eher als nah,
das ist mit dem Flugzeug schnell erreichbar, das ist nicht weit weg und es ist
nur noch ein Land dazwischen, aber,
Und ja, irgendwie nehmen die Leute das hier nicht ernst und ich weiß auch nicht,
wie man es vermitteln sollte.
Also und man will ja auch nicht Panik oder so ein Blödsinn verbreiten oder Propaganda
mit, oh die Russen kommen, aber einfach ein Verständnis schaffen und ich sehe
derzeit nicht, wie man das schaffen könnte.
Ja, wie geht es jetzt weiter mit dem Konflikt? Was denkst du sollte sich jetzt
vielleicht mal wieder auf die deutsche Öffentlichkeit bezogen?
Was kann man am besten tun, um jetzt diesem Konflikt weiter Herr zu werden?
Vielleicht auch aus einer privaten Persönlichkeit.
Ich denke es ist sicherlich wichtig auf die deutsche Politik Einfluss zu nehmen.
Das ist glaube ich das worauf wir eigentlich auch noch am meisten Einfluss haben. Ja.
Ich meine, wir sind eine Demokratie, eine, die funktioniert.
Das heißt, wir können guten Einfluss nehmen.
Ja, man hat bloß nicht so den Eindruck, dass es irgendwie, ich weiß nicht,
also die einzige Partei, die auf mich zumindest den Eindruck macht,
dass sie die Situation in der Ukraine versteht, sind die Grünen.
Was die SPD reitet, ich verstehe es nicht. Naja.
Man will ja seinem Kumpel den Job nicht madig machen. Also ich habe immer das
Gefühl, die haben alle Sorge, dass Gerhard Schröder sonst arm stirbt,
wenn er nicht mehr auf Putins Gehaltsliste sitzt.
Es ist halt auch, ich habe so den Eindruck, dass linke Parteien,
da setze ich jetzt mal ganz große Anführungsstriche drumherum,
weil ich glaube die SPD als linke Partei.
Sie ist so links vom Mittelstrich.
Ja, im besten Falle. Also da sieht sie sich zumindest selber,
ob sie da ist, das lassen wir mal offen.
Aber das ist ja auch generell, das sieht man ja auch jetzt an diesem Wagenknecht-Momentum,
auch generell die Linke als politische Gruppierung, unabhängig von Parteien.
Hat auch schon immer irgendwie so ein komisches Verhältnis gehabt zu Russland und zu Ländern,
die sich in irgendeiner Form gegen die USA stellen.
Also diese Vorstellung, der Imperialismus wäre jetzt so unser Hauptproblem und
alles, was sich in irgendeiner Form dagegen positioniert,
da muss man mal drüber reden, so würde ich das jetzt mal so ein bisschen formulieren.
Man sieht ja auch ähnliche Probleme in der Auseinandersetzung mit Israel,
was ich jetzt nicht aufmachen möchte.
Wir müssen heute noch ins Bett abends.
Ja genau, können wir vielleicht nochmal später aufmachen, das wäre vielleicht
auch nochmal interessant,
da nochmal eine zweite Betrachtung zu machen, aber das scheint hier eine Rolle zu spielen,
sodass einfach auch die politische Landschaft in Deutschland auf so eine Art
und Weise zerklüftet ist, was jetzt die Ukraine-Frage angeht,
wo es schwierig ist, Orientierung zu bekommen. Ja.
Ich habe auch, also Druck auf Politiker machen hat eigentlich...
Immer geholfen, wenn es genug ist. Und das geht ja auf vielen Ebenen.
Ich meine, Demos ist immer sowas, was auf Masse irgendwie eine Tendenz gibt.
Das stört einen Politiker im Normalfall nicht, der irgendwo rumsitzt.
Also mäßig. Es kommt darauf an, wie die Demos verlaufen.
Aber tatsächlich, deswegen haben wir ja zwei Stimmen,
dein Wahlkreisabgeordneten, den halt anschreiben, anrufen, was auch immer.
Wenn nur einer ihm eine Mail schickt, ist das mäßig.
Aber wenn das Büro sagt, ey, die Hälfte der Mails sagen inzwischen,
wir müssen mal mehr für die Ukraine tun, dann denkt der an seine Stimmen bei der nächsten Wahl.
Mein Wahlkreisabgeordneter wird nächste Woche neu gewählt.
Tja, ich möchte nur mal ein Beispiel.
Spiel nennen, als ich mein Panzer hier nach Berlin gebracht habe. Ach ja, gute Story.
Da gab es ja so leichte Service-Schwankungen mit dem Bezirk Mitte.
Da haben wir noch gar nicht drüber gesprochen. Das müssen wir vielleicht gleich nochmal aufmachen.
Und da nur ein Punkt. Ich hatte lange gesagt, der Streit mit dem Bezirk,
ich habe gar keinen Bock, sowas öffentlich zu machen, weil das ist nicht der Punkt.
Das ist nicht, worum es geht. Das ist so bla, mi, mi, mi.
Bis es zu einem Punkt kam, wo ich gesagt habe, jetzt reicht es mir.
Und dann habe ich die ganze Story wie doof die sich verhalten haben, veröffentlicht.
Eine Woche vor der Berlin-Wahl war das, glaube ich. Oder ein oder zwei Wochen.
Und ich habe kein Wort von der Bezirksbürgermeisterin bis dahin irgendwie gehört.
Und in dem Moment, wo dieser Artikel, ich glaube, 200.000 Mal geklickt wurde,
weil es so eine schöne Story war, hat sie mich angerufen, dass wir das doch
mal ganz dringend klären müssen.
Wo ich dachte, ah, eine ungünstige, groß angelegte PR-Aktion kurz vor einer
Wahl kann tatsächlich etwas bewirken und ich meine, das war ein gutes Timing und so.
Nur da habe ich direkt gemerkt, komisch, da besteht auch ein exakter Zusammenhang
zwischen meiner Veröffentlichung und dem plötzlichen Drang zur Kommunikation,
und ich meine, mit Bundestagsabgeordneten und so ist es ja das Gleiche,
nur eben einer alleine kann da oft nicht, also macht nicht den Riesenunterschied,
aber eben jeder kann dem ihm zumindest mailen oder ihn anrufen oder auf Events ansprechen.
Und wenn das halt über eine gewisse Schwelle kommt, dann wird es wahrgenommen.
Und das ist das Gute einer Demokratie. Und da ist auch fast egal,
welche Partei oder welche Ausrichtung der hat.
Wenn seine Wähler sagen, das ist mir ein Anliegen, irgendwann muss er zuhören.
Also entweder versteht er es selbst oder es ist reiner Opportunismus,
dass er sagt, okay, jetzt muss ich mir die Sache angucken.
Aber das ist ja am Ende egal. Aber das ist, glaube ich, das,
womit wir hier echt viel bewegen können und was Leute immer so unterschätzen.
Und umgekehrt eine Online-Petition klicken oder ein Profilbild ändern,
das ist so auf dem unteren Ende von was Wirkung zeigt.
Deinen Abgeordneten persönlich nerven, kann ich sagen, wirkt oft Wunder,
zumindest dass es irgendwo auf die Agenda kommt.
Jetzt müssen wir aber die Sache mit dem Panzer Das hatten.
Wir gar nicht, ne? In der letzten Sendung.
Nein, weil wir hatten das ja im April 20, also ein Monat, zwei Monate nach dem Krieg.
Wir hatten uns zwischenzeitlich mal getroffen und darüber gesprochen.
Das war es. Deswegen hatte ich im Kopf.
Genau. Und da war das sozusagen auch noch ongoing. Da war das sozusagen mitten in diesem Konflikt.
Ja.
Also dein Plan war ja, einen dieser zerstörten russischen Panzer in Berlin auszustellen,
so wie es die Ukraine zu dem Zeitpunkt ja in Kiew und später dann auch in anderen
europäischen Städten gemacht hat.
Ich weiß nicht, wo das in Kiew war.
Vor dem Hotel, wo die internationale Presse war. Welch Zufall, direkt vor der Tür.
Das ist aber nicht Maidan, sondern es ist eine andere Gegend.
Ja, es ist nur so 200 Meter von Maidan die Straße hoch, also so den Hügel hoch
Und oben ist das Intercontinental Hotel, wo zu der Zeit alle waren.
Also Intercontinental Kiew. Und daneben ist das Kloster, dessen Namen ich immer vergesse.
Und das hat so einen großen Vorplatz. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob der zum Hotel gehört oder was auch immer.
Aber auf jeden Fall, das ist der Riesenplatz, auf dem das alles stand.
Wir schauen hier gerade mal auf die Karte. Also es ist auf jeden Fall mitten im Zentrum.
Genau. Ach hier, das Denkmal für die Vierfüßin Olga, also was wir hier nur sehen.
Das ist der Platz, auf dem die ganzen Panzer dann, oder also jetzt mal Panzer,
mal Traktoren, mal was auch immer stehen.
Eine interessante Sache ist dieses Denkmal. Ich glaube, das ist sogar auf deinem
Bild zu sehen, hier auf Google Earth gerade.
Das ist eins von den riesen Denkmälern, die mit Sandsäcken am Anfang des Krieges
verhüllt wurden, wo es so diese Videos gab, wie Freiwillige zehn Meter hohe
Star-Tour in Tag- und Nachtarbeit mit Sandsäcken umhüllt haben.
Nannten sie dann auch die Monuments Man, also wie die damals im Zweiten Weltkrieg
und dann der gleichnamige Film, die, die die Kunst und Kultur schützen vorm Krieg.
Inzwischen ist dieses Datum wieder frei und trägt eine schusssichere Weste,
eine überdimensionale.
Und damit werben sie für ein Crowdfunding für Westen, für Frauen an der Front.
Also deswegen diese Star-Tour hat sozusagen mehrere Geschichten des Krieges
alleine zu erzählen, was auch abgefahren ist und als wir Ende März 2022 da ankamen auf dem Platz,
war die Star-Tour glaube ich gerade verhüllt und es hing ein riesen Banner dran,
den jemand so per Hand gesprüht oder gemalt hatte,
wo nur riesig groß drauf stand World Help Us.
Und das fand ich auch so sehr einfach, aber sehr eindringlich,
das halt auf Englisch und direkt da, wo den ganzen Tag die Weltpresse hin und
her lief, also dass man jeden Tag daran erinnert wird.
Das war sozusagen gut gemachtes Selbstmarketing.
Du wolltest also jetzt so ein Panzer nach Berlin holen.
Wie bist du das angegangen? Was ist da der erste Schritt?
Also das war wieder so eine Sache von jemand sollte mal. Also warum gibt es das nicht in Berlin?
Ja, warum macht das denn keiner? Genau.
Warum jemand anders müsste mal tun. Und dann haben wir gesagt,
sollen wir das machen? Ich habe gesagt, boah, kein Bock.
Ich habe so viele Dinge den Tag lang.
Also ich kriege den Tag echt so voll.
Aber wenn es keiner macht, wie immer, wenn die Welt fragt, dann muss ich sie
retten. Das alte Problem. Gut. Und dann?
Superheldenalltag. Genau.
Das Übliche. Und dann habe ich gedacht, okay, wie fängt man an?
Und ich dachte eigentlich am Anfang, nie im Leben klappt das.
Das ist so kompliziert, aber ich kann es ja versuchen.
Und dann kann ich in alle Ewigkeit sagen, Leute, ich habe es versucht.
Ich habe ja auch versucht, der Bundeswehr die MiG-29 abzukaufen und in die Ukraine zu schicken.
Das hat auch nicht geklappt. Ich kann immer sagen, ich habe es versucht.
Ich habe den E-Mail-Verkehr mit dem Verteidigungsministerium.
Sie wollten nicht mal wissen, über welches Unternehmen in Jordanien ich die
kaufen will. Das endete schon vorher.
Ich weiß nicht, die waren nicht so offen für meine Ideen.
Ich hatte auch mal die Idee, als sie den Bundestag schützen wollten,
als es diese Ideen gab, einen Graben zu ziehen, habe ich gesagt,
ey, ich habe gute Erfahrungen mit Flammenwerfern.
Habt ihr darüber mal nachgedacht? Ich habe die Antwort von der Bundestagsverwaltung,
dass sie nicht über Flammenwerfer nachdenken.
Sind eigentlich super für sowas, aber okay.
Aber so, man hat ja seine Ideen. Und so eigentlich kam das für mich in diese Richtung.
Und dann gedacht, okay, wo anfangen?
Ich habe gesagt, das Einfachste ist, Ich schicke der ukrainischen Botschaft
in Deutschland eine Mail.
Einfach ganz knapp, kein bla bla bla, kein wie so ein Projektpitch,
sondern ich mache nur zwei, drei Sätze und sage, hey, ich habe das gesehen,
ich würde das gerne machen, weil damit ist die Idee ja klar.
Da muss ich nicht mehr erklären.
Mit wem kann ich sprechen oder wer kann mir helfen?
Irgendwie so. Und dann dachte ich, okay, und jetzt habe ich einen Monat Ruhe
und dann kann ich sagen, ich habe es versucht.
Fünf Minuten später kommt eine Mail, ja, hier, ich wäre zuständig,
kannst du mir mal eine Handynummer geben? Dachte so, oh fuck, it's on.
Dann habe ich der Dame, die zuständig ist, meine Nummer gegeben und sie sagt,
geile Idee, was brauchst du? Sagt ja mal ein Panzer.
Sagt, okay, ja, ich schicke dir gleich einen WhatsApp-Kontakt,
den kannst du fragen. Ich dachte so, ernsthaft?
Man malt sich ja aus, wie unglaublich komplex das ist.
Und dann so, spricht der Englisch? Ja, das Juri, der spricht Englisch. Was macht der?
Was kann der? Ich frage ihn einfach so, hallo, du bist Juri?
Ja, kannst du mir einen Panzer geben?
Oh nein, oh nein, ja, oh Gott, oh Gott, dachte, was ist jetzt los?
Sagt der Herr, die haben mir schon gesagt, du willst irgendwie einen Panzer
und ich weiß auch nicht, wie das geht.
Wo war der jetzt? In der Ukraine?
Wo ist die Beziehung zum Panzer? Okay, er hat dann so Events organisiert für
die Armee, also so, die haben ja auch dauernd irgendwas.
Da haben sie gesagt, ein Panzer, ein Panzer, hinstellen.
Es ist nicht Logistik, weil wir fahren den nicht, der gehört uns auch gar nicht
direkt. Es ist ein Event. Juri, wir haben ein Event.
Deine Abteilung. Und er sagt, was?
Und dann saßen wir da irgendwie so insgesamt zu dritt, also bei unserer Seite
so Wieland Giebel, mit dem ich auch das Museum hier mache, der auch sagte,
geile Idee, ich habe nicht mal eine To-Do.
Also wo fängt man, also wenn du einen Podcast machst, hast du so zwei,
drei Ideen, okay, du brauchst ein Mikrofon, du brauchst das Aufnahmegerät,
beim Panzer so, okay, ich bin dabei, ich weiß nur nicht bei was.
Okay, also waren wir zu dritt, er sagt, lass mal einen Zoom-Call machen.
Und dann sagte der, ja, er weiß, wo die Panzer stehen. Er muss mal klären,
wie der rechtliche Ablauf überhaupt ist.
Da habe ich gesagt, Moment, aber es waren doch welche in Prag und in,
wo noch? Habe ich vergessen, auf jeden Fall in Prag waren welche.
Warschau.
Ja, genau, Prag und Warschau. Und der sagte, ja, aber da haben sozusagen die
Armeen oder so die geholt, was also rechtlich quasi gar nichts ist.
Die laden die auf, können ihre Genehmigungen selber stempeln und die Regierung
sagt, das ist okay. okay, aber es hat noch nie ein Zivilist angerufen und gesagt,
kann ich einen Panzer haben?
Sie müssen jetzt mal die Rahmenbedingungen klären.
Die Bundeswehr ist auf die Idee noch nicht gekommen.
Ich habe die Bundeswehr gefragt, die war nicht begeistert von der Idee, um es kurz zu sagen.
Es war ein sehr kurzer Kontakt.
Okay.
So und dann, weil es sagt, okay, muss man selber machen.
Und dann, es dauerte eine ganze Weile, weil ganz viel hin und her war und parallel,
er sagt, wer ist jetzt genau zuständig, weil, also ich habe früher Veranstaltungen
organisiert in Berlin, aber muss jetzt gucken, gibt es irgendwas Besonderes.
Dann haben wir überlegt, er sagt, pass auf, ich versuche diesen Panzerrand zu
schaffen und Wieland versucht das mit den Behörden zu klären,
dass wir so eine grobe Einteilung haben, weil ich war zu der Zeit viel in der
Ukraine und er war mehr hier. Okay.
Dann hat er halt gesagt, naja, eigentlich ist das eine Sache vom Bezirk,
eine Veranstaltung, also Sondernutzung für kulturelle Zwecke.
Er hat gesagt, was genau ist das rechtlich?
Und dann haben wir gesagt, naja, aus meiner Sicht ist es eine Kunstinstallation,
weil es kann ja viel sein.
Es kann eine Demonstration sein, es könnte Kunst sein und so weiter.
Ich habe gesagt, damit will ich meinen Gedanken Ausdruck verleihen über den Krieg.
Ich habe mehrere künstlerische Sachen gemacht. Das ist eine Kunstinstallation.
Der Vorteil ist, vom Grundgesetz geschützt.
Und eine Demo kann man argumentieren, dass sie an verschiedenen Orten stattfinden kann.
Wenn zu meiner Kunstinstallation das gesamte Ensemble gehört,
dann kann man es nicht verschieben.
So. Und dann ist man ganz schnell bei Dingen wie, ich glaube,
Bundesgerichtshof oder Verfassungsgericht irgendwas ganz weit oben,
wenn man das durchexerzieren will.
So, und dann, okay.
Ging es ein bisschen hin und her und dann war der rechtliche Weg klar,
wie der Panzer aus der Ukraine hier hinkommen kann, also was die Ukrainer machen
müssen, was sie von uns brauchen, welche Dokumente und hin und her.
Es war so ein bisschen Kleinkram, aber an sich war der Weg klar. Klar.
Und dann hat Wieland halt an das Bezirksamt geschickt, hier,
wir wollen die Veranstaltung hier anmelden.
Und ich habe ja gesagt, ey, lass uns nicht erwähnen, dass wir einen Panzer bringen,
weil sonst stellen die Fragen.
Der hat gesagt, ich glaube, wenn wir das Detail weglassen, dann gibt es Probleme.
Das ist doch nicht so eine gute Idee. Okay.
Also haben wir reingeschrieben, genau was wir wollen und es hat einfach niemand reagiert.
Beim Bezirksamt. Genau, auf deinem Bezirksamt. Und dann nach einem Monat habe
ich durch Zufall mit Leuten vom Tagesspiegel gesprochen und die fanden die Idee
auch lustig und sagen, wie, die haben nicht reagiert.
Kannst du uns mal den Mailverkehr und so irgendwie schicken oder wenn das nicht
geht, also kannst du uns sagen wann und an wen und so.
Denen das geschickt, dann haben die beim Bezirk gefragt, was los?
Und innerhalb von Stunden bekam ich eine Eingangsbestätigung.
Ich dachte, komisch, monatelang nix und dann aber es kam an,
okay, hat irgendwie jemand das Postfach aufgemacht. Und dann kam...
Also sie sind nicht inhaltlich drauf eingegangen, sondern nur,
dass du überhaupt angefragt hast.
Und da muss man sagen, ist der Tagesspiegel grandios, wenn die was interessiert,
dann geht es ja richtig ab und die haben jeden Tag gefragt, so, wo Panzer? Wo Panzer?
Wo Panzer? Das Bezirksamt, also Alter, also ich kann mir vorstellen,
dass die irgendwie, so wo Panzer.
Und naja, nach einer Woche bekam ich dann eine Absage vom Bezirksamt und man
könnte es grob zusammenfassen, es war bla.
Klar, zum einen, das ist gar keine Kunstinstallation, sondern ist es halt nicht.
Und zum anderen geht das auch eh nicht mit einem Panzer, weil da könnten Menschen drin gestorben sein.
Und das Interessante war, sie haben nie mit mir gesprochen, nie nach einem künstlerischen
Konzept gefragt, aber sie wussten, dass das keine Kunst ist.
Und, dass in dem Panzer Menschen gestorben sein könnten, könnte,
könnte nicht, könnte, könnte, könnte ist kein rechtlicher Begriff.
Ich sagte, okay, das heißt, den Bundestag können wir auch nicht mehr benutzen,
weil da sind ja auch im Krieg Menschen drin gestorben.
Martin Gropiusbau.
Wahrscheinlich auch im Bezirksamt Mitte. Genau.
Wenn man das Argument anführt, also es ist keins und das war nur so bla bla bla.
Okay, dann irgendwie, habe ich auch gesagt, was macht man jetzt?
Und dann meldete sich Dr.
Patrick Heinemann, inzwischen kennen wir ihn als den Dog Slayer,
also der, der jedes Bezirksamt erschlägt, weil er der Beste ist.
Es ist ein Anwalt für Verwaltungsrecht.
Das Spannendste, was ein Jurist tun kann. Ich dachte, oh Gott, oh Gott, oh Gott.
Also so meine erste Idee war, oh fuck, wie wimmel ich den ab?
So ein Fachanwalt für Verwaltungsrecht klingt jetzt nicht nach dem, den man braucht.
Und da habe ich gemerkt, doch, doch, das ist genau der, den man braucht.
Und der hat gesagt, boah, lass uns die platt machen. Und zwar sowas von,
sodass da nicht mal mehr Rauch kommt.
Und da habe ich gedacht, Verwaltungsrecht kann spannend sein,
Nein, wenn man Patrick Heinemann heißt, ja.
Und der hat dann gesagt, okay, welche Argumente könnten die bringen?
Hat eine lange Liste gemacht mit allem Blödsinn, den sie bringen könnten.
Hat zu jedem Punkt die besten Gutachter in Deutschland gesucht und sie vorsorglich
Gutachten schreiben lassen, die das aufarbeiten.
Also schon mal vorab sozusagen, bevor auch nur irgendwas in diesem Punkt,
ist das nicht sauteuer? Ja?
Jein. Es ist es wert. So rum haben wir uns nachher gehandelt. Okay.
Also ihr habt da wirklich Geld in die Hand genommen?
Ja. Also sagen wir mal so, von meiner ersten E-Mail bis der Panzer da stand,
waren es 100.000 Euro ungefähr.
Also alle Kosten, alles zusammen, was irgendwie irgendwas damit zu tun hatte. Nein. Ja.
Okay. So und dann ging es los.
Also Heinemann hat gesagt, okay, erstmal müssen wir Widerspruch einreichen.
Also das ist erstmal nur, glaube ich nicht.
Und wenn das nicht geht, dann geht es zur Klage. Das sind so die Schritte.
Okay, dann hat er gesagt, hallo, ich vertrete das jetzt und irgendwie,
das kann ich nicht nachvollziehen.
Hin und her, das ging vor Gericht und das Gericht hat gesagt,
oh komm Leute, dann sagt mal beide, was ihr wollt.
Welches Gericht?
Das war das Verwaltungsgericht in Berlin. Erstmal sowas Niedriges, wo es anfängt.
Aber da habe ich gemerkt, mit Heinemann fängt es nicht niedrig an.
Also das ist so sozusagen, das ist wie wenn du jemanden im Park überfallen willst
und er schießt mit dem Panzer zurück. Das ist so ungefähr die Reaktion, die bei ihm kam.
Das Bezirksamt hat gesagt, also hier sind unsere drei Seiten,
was wir irgendwie glauben und Heinemann sagt, hier sind unsere 300 Seiten mit
den Fachgutachten und übrigens,
wir haben hier eine Zusage bis Bundesgerichtshof, also macht mal keine Sorge,
wir kloppen die Sache durch.
Und wenn ihr noch irgendwas habt, wir hätten gerne in sieben Tagen Antwort, weil wir haben es eilig.
Und übrigens, diese anderen Anwälte können wir hinzuziehen, wenn es Probleme gibt.
Da dachte man, okay, das ist irgendwie so Kneipenschlägerei,
aber du hast zwei Klitschkos bei oder sowas.
Also irgendwie war das ein sehr unfairer Kampf auf den ersten Blick,
wo ich dachte, der weiß wie es geht.
Und halt bevor das sozusagen vor Gericht ging, hatten wir immer gesagt,
können wir uns mal einfach zusammensetzen und irgendwie, also bevor es überhaupt
einen Rechtsstreit gab, haben wir gesagt, hier ist unsere Idee,
lass uns mal treffen. Nein.
Dann hatten die das halt nochmal gefragt, nein und dann hat der richtig drauf gekloppt.
Und zwar sowas von, also der Anwalt, dass da echt das Bezirksamt irgendwie keinen Bock mehr hatte.
Aber die hatten keinen Bock, aber blöde Ideen.
Was war denn dann der nächste Schritt?
Erstmal ging es hin und her, dass zig Briefe zum Gericht und die haben einen
Punkt gehabt, wir haben erwidert, die haben einen Punkt gehabt.
Zum Beispiel hatten sie so schlaue Punkte wie,
Jogger könnten vor den Panzer rennen. Das ist kein Spaß.
Du glaubst nicht, man denkt, das kann kein... Das Rechtsamt der Bezirksbürgermeisterin
von Berlin-Mitte. Da gibt es Leute, die so was schreiben.
Du hast noch nicht gesagt, wo der Panzer eigentlich stehen sollte.
Genau, das war so ein Detail. Wir haben gesagt, wir müssen ja verhandeln.
Ich dachte, ich schlage eine blöde Idee vor. Wir treffen uns im Bezirksamt und
dann geht es los wie auf dem Bazar. Und man feilscht so ein bisschen.
Was ist das Höchste, wo wir ansetzen können? damit wir uns dann irgendwo aufs Mittelfeld einigen.
Sagt, wir wollen einen vollen Kampfpanzer vor die russische Botschaft stellen.
Die Idee ist so bescheuert, das geht nie im Leben. Und dann gucken wir mal,
weißt du, wo wir so verhandlungstechnisch landen, ob wir dann Schützenpanzer
irgendwo auf dem Tempelhofer Feld haben oder so am Ende.
Und russische Botschaft, muss man dazu wissen, in Berlin heißt auf dem Kurfürsten...
Unter den Linden.
Entschuldigung. In Berlin heißt unter den Linden im...
Vorm Brandenburger Tor sozusagen.
Blickweite des Brandenburger Tors.
Genau, also da der Mittelpunkt, so da, wo es abgeht.
Ja, und dann, aber weil der Bezirk nie mit uns sprechen wollte und wir nicht
mehr darüber nachgedacht haben, ging es dann so vor Gericht.
Wir dachten, stimmt, okay, das war mal die Idee, dann ist das jetzt halt,
was verhandelt wird und gar nicht mehr irgendwas anderes.
Und dann war also, sie hatten Sorge, das Bezirksamt mit hatte Sorge,
Jogger könnten vorrennen.
Oder, wenn Radfahrer da langfahren, dass sie sich so erschrecken, dass sie umfallen.
Oder, naja, du weißt ja, wie die Sorge vor Radfahrern im Straßenverkehr in Berlin haben.
Jogger, also Jogger unter den Linden.
Wir haben uns das alles so bildlich vorgestellt.
Da sind keine Jogger.
Nein.
Da ist alles voll mit Touristen.
Dann, es könnte Kriegsflüchtlinge traumatisieren.
Und ich weiß gar nicht, was noch kam. Es kam eine Sache nach dem anderen,
aber immer ohne Beleg, sondern so, wir glauben das.
Und das Gericht hat jedes Mal
gesagt, okay, könnt ihr das irgendwie untermauern? Okay, könnt ihr nicht.
Und das wurde auch so langweilig, weil es halt immer so ein Stuss war.
Und irgendwann, irgendwann war es dann so, dass es wirklich sozusagen zum Richterspruch
kam. und der hat gesagt, lieber Bezirk, ihr habt ganz tolle Sachen vorgebracht.
Nicht einer davon trifft diesen Rechtsbereich, von dem wir sprechen.
Ihr habt nämlich mit allmöglichen argumentiert, was ihr glaubt und meint und
vielleicht, aber es war am Ende Straßenverkehrsrecht und ihr habt nicht einen
Punkt angebracht, der damit zu tun hatte.
Das ist das ganze Problem. Also auch so fachlich daneben.
Und dann, ich weiß gar nicht, also die ganzen Details sind elendig lang,
da kann ich ich kann es ja sonst in die Shownotes den Link packen,
weil das sind zwei Sendungen voll.
Ja, das machen wir eh.
Genau, und dann war es aber so, der Punkt, der dann sozusagen für mich das Fass
aber zum Überlaufen gebracht hat, bis dahin dachte ich, das ist lustig und lächerlich,
das ist so doof und darum geht es mir nicht. Mir geht es darum,
diese Installation zu machen.
Und dann war es so, wir hatten quasi vor Gericht gewonnen.
Was ich nicht wusste, ist, dass so eine Erlaubnis dann 14 Tage gilt,
ab dem Richterspruch. Und ich habe gesagt, öh.
Und wir haben dem Gericht das dann mitgeteilt, haben gesagt,
also ich weiß nicht, wie das rechtlich ist, aber wir müssen, also.
Das ist unser Problem. Wir wissen jetzt nicht, was das für den Prozess innerhalb
der Ukraine heißt und für die Genehmigung und sowas.
Wir bitten halt um Aufschub, weil wir müssen jetzt erstmal gucken, wie es weitergeht.
Und daraufhin hat das Rechtsamt der Bezirksbürgermeisterin dem Gericht geschrieben,
das verstehen sie nicht und halten sie für nicht nachvollziehbar,
dieses Argument. Und deswegen bitten sie darum, dass das Urteil wieder gekippt wird.
Und.
Da hat das Gericht ihn auch recht knapp geschrieben, dass auf diesem Niveau
hier nichts stattfindet.
Also zu sagen, wir können nicht nachvollziehen, dass der Sachbearbeiter bei
einem Kriegsverbrechen getötet wurde.
Nein, nein, so funktioniert das hier nicht. Und da merkt man so in den Zeilen,
der Richter war wohl wirklich erbost, dass man sowas jetzt versucht auszunutzen,
um da seine Scheiße durchzudrücken.
Und da habe ich auch gedacht, sorry, aber tiefer geht es nicht mehr im Niveau, oder?
Dann habe ich halt die ganze Sache aufgeschrieben und bis dann hatte ich halt
null Kontakt zu der Bürgermeisterin oder zur Stadträtin, die zuständig ist oder
irgendwas, weil die halt jeglichen Kontakt abgelehnt haben.
Dann habe ich den ganzen Kram aufgeschrieben und es ist echt seitenlang,
weil es so viele bizarre Nebenaspekte hatte.
Und das war halt so ein, zwei Wochen, bevor wir hier die Wahl hatten, 2022 dann.
Und dann war es so, dass die, dann hat halt die Bürgermeisterin oder ihr Büro
sich sofort gemeldet, ob wir nicht mal ganz dringend sprechen sollten.
Nachdem wie viel Zeit mittlerweile vergangen war?
Sechs Monate und Gerichtsverfahren und alles.
Aber warte, spar dir dein Lachen, das Ruhig-Dich-Lustige kommt noch.
Sie sagte mir am Telefon, sie hat nie davon gehört.
Sie wusste nichts davon, dass wir das planen. Sie hat nie in der Zeitung davon
gelesen. Sie hat nichts von der Rechtsabteilung gewusst. Sie wusste gar nichts davon.
Ernsthaft?
Ja, das war ernsthaft ihre Position. Und das Rechtsamt der Bezirksbürgermeisterin
Berlin-Mitte, Das hätte mit ihr auch eigentlich gar nichts zu tun.
Okay, das klingt jetzt vom Namen her anders.
Nee, die hätten da selber gehandelt ohne irgendeine Anweisung.
Ich dachte, ich weiß nicht genau, wie das funktioniert.
Das heißt, so ein Rechtsamt sitzt da morgens, macht ein Teammeeting und jeder
pitcht, wo sie klagen wollen oder wie soll ich mir das vorstellen?
Ich weiß nicht, ich habe da Zweifel an dieser Darstellung, um es mal so zu sagen. Ja.
Also ich meine spätestens, wenn man gegen das Bezirksamt klagt,
das war ja dann sozusagen der, ich meine die stellen auch Leute.
Sie haben mehrere Kanzleien beauftragt.
Das macht das Rechtsamt auch einmal. Das Rechtsamt klingt für mich eher so wie
Rechtspflege, die sich sozusagen den normalen Prozess dessen,
was ohnehin anliegt, aber keine lokalpolitischen Entscheidungen. Nein.
Und naja, aber das war ihr Standpunkt. Sie hat da nie von gehört.
Sie hat auch gar nichts gegen und das ist alles okay.
Aha, auf einmal.
Er hat gesagt, gut, wo ist die Genehmigung? Ganz einfach, weil das Gericht hat
sie verpflichtet, eine Genehmigung auszustellen.
Davon habe ich die noch nicht.
Und dann kamen wieder eine Million Details und am Ende war es so,
der Panzer war demilitarisiert, verladen, auf dem Weg hierhin mit allen Papieren
ausgestattet, alles fertig.
Aber die Zeit wurde immer und immer und immer und immer knapper,
weil das halt alles auf den letzten Drücker war.
Und es war so, an einem Freitag war der 24.02., also der Jahrestag des Überfalls
und da sollte er hier stehen und am Mittwoch hatte er die Ukraine noch nicht verlassen.
Und das ist ein Schwertransporter mit vier Meter Breite und ich glaube 80 Tonnen
Gesamtgewicht und der darf nur nachts fahren.
Er sagt, okay, der muss noch drei Nächte fahren und wir haben anderthalb.
Ich glaube, ich sehe ein Problem. Sie sagten, nein. Nein.
Und er hat gesagt, okay. Und das andere Doofe war, weil immer noch nicht klar
war, ob die Aktion stattfindet, viele Journalisten, die ich auch gut kenne,
haben gesagt, sag mal, ist das, also wann sagt ihr denen jetzt mal, ob es klappt oder nicht?
Und ich habe gesagt, ich weiß es nicht. Das ist nicht irgendein Werbegag,
das ist nicht irgendwie Suspense.
Es ist in zwei Tagen und wir wissen auch nicht, ob es funktioniert.
Was meinst du, wie genervt ich gerade bin und ich hatte noch keine Genehmigung.
Das war dann noch ein Punkt.
Eigentlich sollte der dann mit einem Kran abgeladen werden. Es gibt genau an
der Stelle vor der russischen Botschaft, also unter den Linden,
hat so, ich glaube, drei, vier Fahrspuren pro Richtung.
Und in der Mitte so eine Mittelpromenade, die zehn Meter breit ist oder so.
Also so eine richtige Flaniermeile.
Und an einer Stelle gibt es wie so eine Wendespur. Also wo die Mittelpromenade
unterbrochen ist von einer richtigen asphaltierten Spur.
Und genau dort sollte der Panzer stehen, weil das eben das Gewicht hält.
Und diese Mittelpromenade oder diese Wendespur ist so breit,
dass man den Panzer in Fahrtrichtung auf die eine Hälfte hätte stellen können
und die andere Hälfte wäre noch frei gewesen für Fußgänger und Radfahrer.
Und das war so ursprünglich der Plan.
Und dann hätte das Kanonenrohr entweder Richtung Brandenburger Tor oder Richtung
Alexanderplatz gezeigt, was mir eigentlich egal war, weil das ist nicht der Punkt.
Detail, ja.
Eine Woche, dann also am Freitag, bevor das aufgestellt werden sollte,
hieß es dann auf einmal, ja, ihr könnt den Kran aber gar nicht aufbauen.
Und er sagt, warum nicht? Ja, weil der ist zu schwer. Das geht nicht.
Er sagt, okay, der Panzer ist verladen und alles. Was heißt,
hier geht nicht? Ja, geht nicht und Ende der Durchsage.
Dann haben wir das Kranunternehmen gefragt, haben gesagt, hey,
wir haben ein Gerichtsurteil, stellt ihr trotzdem auf?
Und die sagen, ne, ohne Genehmigung vom Bezirksamt geht gar nichts,
weil sonst fahren wir nie wieder einen Kran in Berlin. So, okay, verständlich.
Sagt, wie ist das jetzt, wenn wir einfach den Tieflader da parken?
Die haben gesagt, du findest kein Schwerlastunternehmen, was den Scheiß mitmacht.
Genau aus dem gleichen Grund. Also niemand wird ohne Brief und Siegel das Ding
da auch nur in die Stadt fahren.
Und wir hatten sozusagen die Genehmigung, den Panzer hinzufahren.
Also da muss man dann, kriegst du so eine Genehmigung, auf welchen Straßen du
den Schwerlasttransport machen darfst.
Aber bis du nicht den Stempel fürs Abstellen hast, findest du kein Unternehmen,
was das durchführt. Und da haben wir gesagt, okay.
Am Ende hat das Bezirksamt also gewusst, wie so eine Nummer läuft,
mit ihrer längeren Erfahrung sozusagen, wie man einen da nerven kann.
Gut, aber wie gesagt, dann hatten wir noch zwei Tage und haben den Ukrainern
gesagt, das ist das Problem.
Und sie sagten, kein Problem, kein Problem, bleib ruhig, bleibt entspannt,
wir haben alles im Griff.
Und ich sagte, wie? Bleib ruhig, bleib ruhig.
Und wir hatten halt ein Unternehmen beauftragt, ein ukrainisches,
ist, den Transport durchzuführen und alles gut, aber es war so okay.
Und irgendwie der Kontakt war auch ein bisschen schwierig und kompliziert.
Er sagt, nee, entspannt euch. Der steht da.
Und dann habe ich die Handynummer von einem der Fahrer bekommen und also habe
dem gewhatsappt und sage, ey, sag mir, wenn ihr über die Grenze seid und ob ihr das schafft.
Und der sagte, ey, bleibt ruhig, alles okay, alles okay, wir sind schon in der Grenzkontrolle.
Ich dachte so, ey, es sind noch 36 Stunden oder so, es kann gar nicht mehr gehen.
Und dann gab es wohl einiges hin und her.
Wir haben nur aus Gerüchten erfahren, dass es sehr hoch ging in der polnischen
Regierung, dass die gesagt haben, an uns soll es nicht scheitern,
dass der Panzer vor der Botschaft steht.
Also haben sie auf einmal 24-7 diesen Transport durch Polen fahren dürfen.
Am helllichten Tag auf der Autobahn mit voller Sperrung, weil der zwei Spuren
gebraucht hat und jetzt scheiß drauf, gib Gas.
Am Abend riefen die an, sie sind Frankfurt-Oder. Sie stehen jetzt vor der Grenze
und ich habe dann auch später mit Leuten gesprochen, die mit so Schwertransporten
zu tun haben. Die haben gesagt, kann nicht sein. Nein. Okay.
Stopp. Und dann habe ich gesagt, was ist mit der Genehmigung,
die dann immer noch nicht klar war. Und die haben gesagt, ja, äh, äh, äh,
Der Laster ist nicht zivil. Der gehört dem Verteidigungsministerium.
Wir haben kein Problem mit dem ukrainischen.
Wir haben kein Problem mit, wo der steht, wo eine Genehmigung ist, wo ein Stempel ist.
Weil?
Weil es ist ein Verteidigungsministerium-Laster. Wenn die den da hin parken,
ist es kein deutsches Schwerlastunternehmen, was Probleme mit dem Bezirksamt
Mitte bekommt, wenn es nochmal hier rumfahren will.
Achso, okay, ja.
Das interessiert den Scheißdreck. Also nicht.
Weil die einen Freibrief haben.
Sondern weil die einfach….
Für die sie aber verpflichtet wurden vom Gericht, die auszustellen.
Das Verfahren will ich sehen. Also da will ich sehen, wie das irgendwie rechtlich aussieht.
Weil ich glaube nicht, dass man das gewinnen kann, wenn das Gericht gesagt hat,
du musst das stempeln und du tust es nicht.
Jetzt war nur ein Problem. Der Panzer sollte halt eigentlich sozusagen in Fahrtrichtung
stehen, dass er nicht die ganze Mittelpromenade blockiert und abgeladen werden.
Jetzt konnten wir ihn nicht abladen. Und mit dem Tieflader und so hätte man
die gesamte Mittelpromenade quer blockiert.
Und der Anwalt sagte, hey, in diesem Gerichtsurteil steht nicht,
wie der Panzer stehen muss.
Das Urteil ist die Grundlage, was der Bezirk will, ist uns völlig egal.
Also stand der Trailer quer, hat alles blockiert, kam dann mitten in der Nacht
an, der Fahrer ist ausgestiegen, hat die Zugmaschine abgekoppelt und ist gefahren.
Wir standen dort mit bestimmt 20 Polizisten, die die sagten,
können wir mal die Genehmigung sehen.
Sagt er aber natürlich, wir haben ja eine, wir dürfen nur nicht abladen.
Und dann war ein Polizist bei, der fachkundig wohl war und der wissen wollte,
wie genau der demilitarisiert wurde. Das konnte ich ihm genau erklären.
Wir hatten die Bescheinigung vom ukrainischen Verteidigungsministerium,
dass der demilitarisiert ist und vom deutschen BAFA, die für solche Dinge zuständig sind.
Demilitarisiert heißt, dass er nicht schießen kann.
Kann nicht schießen, kann nicht fahren, die Panzerung muss noch an,
Da gibt es ein paar Auflagen.
Der Polizist war auch ganz entspannt, weil also sozusagen der Anwalt hat sich
über irgendwelche Dinge mit denen eingestritten und der wollte aber einfach
nur wissen, kann das Ding schießen?
Vor allem, weil das Rohr auf die russische Botschaft zeigte,
so wie der abgestellt war.
Ich habe ihm das gezeigt, er sagte, alles klar, kann ich schießen,
der Rest nicht mein Ding. Das ist das Einzige, was mich interessiert.
So und dann stand der Panzer da und die Polizei war auch so wohl so mittelzufrieden,
weil also sagen wir mal grundsätzlich sind die ja neutral,
was so Sachen angeht, aber sie merkten halt nicht, dass sie sozusagen der Panzer interessiert,
aber sie waren sozusagen als der Spielball zwischen den Politikern,
die es nicht wollen und uns, die es gemacht haben und jetzt stehen sie blöd
dazwischen und irgendwie so man merkte, sie haben keinen Bock drauf,
weil da müsste die Bezirksbürgermeisterin jetzt stehen.
Und irgendwie das klären oder jemand anders, also es ist nicht Aufgabe der Polizei
so was, was so schief lief, irgendwie eine Meinung auch nur zuzuhaben.
Da haben sie gesagt, okay,
geguckt aufs Kennzeichen, das geklärt, dass sie da mäßig jetzt etwas noch machen
können und dann hieß es, gut, dann steht der hier.
Wir haben formal eine Genehmigung, irgendetwas irgendwie aufzustellen.
Ja, dann ist es so.
Dann passt das schon so.
Ja, und so stand er dann da.
Und der stand aber nur bis, ich glaube drei Tage oder so, bis Dienstagabend da.
Das war ganz interessant. Dann rief die Polizei an und sagte,
ich muss sofort unverzüglich mit dem Fahrer mit der Zugmaschine kommen.
Das ist sofort zu räumen wegen Gefahr im Verzug. Er hat gesagt,
okay, wir haben aber keinerlei Erlaubnis, den jetzt zu bewegen.
Also wir haben weder eine Route, die uns freigegeben wurde, man muss halt für
diese Dinger das immer beantragen, ist egal, ist egal, die Polizei Berlin übernimmt
die Verantwortung, sie sperren die Route komplett ab und wir müssen sofort mit
dem Ding aus Berlin raus.
Und was ist die Gefahr, die im Verzug war?
Können Sie nicht sagen.
Aber da müssen Sie ja irgendwoher haben, die Informationen.
Wollten Sie auch dem Anwalt nicht sagen. Können Sie nicht sagen,
aber Sie ordnen jetzt sofortiges Entfernen an.
Dann haben wir gesagt, okay. Und der Anwalt sagte, naja, an sich,
wenn die das anordnen, ist es erstmal so.
Man kann nachher dagegen vorgehen, aber man kann jetzt gerade nichts machen.
Und die haben gesagt, das Einfachste ist, wir fahren in echt mit unserem Fahrer
weg und unserer Zugmaschine, weil dann wissen wir, was passiert.
Sonst wird es nur komplizierter. Dann kommt er auf ein Sicherstellungsgelände
vielleicht oder wie auch immer.
Keiner weiß es genau, was der Plan ist für Panzer, die man abschleppt.
Und so dämlich. Und sag mal so, auch wieder die Polizisten vor Ort, die waren ganz nett.
Die hatten halt den Auftrag gekriegt, das Ding muss weg, fertig.
Also so, hatten wir alle das gleiche Problem.
Und die hatten dann nur gefragt, wie ist der denn hier hingekommen?
Weil die Strecke, die hingeht, muss ja auch zurückgehen.
Waren so ein paar Probleme. Zum einen, sie war nicht gesperrt.
Zum anderen mussten wir gegen Einbahnstraßen fahren und solche Sachen.
Die haben gesagt, ist egal, ist egal. Egal, die hatten ohne Ende Polizeiwagen
und Busse da, die haben unter den Linden vorne und hinten komplett abgesperrt.
Das wurde noch wilder, die haben Teile von der A100 gesperrt.
Also ich habe das Video, wie die Auffahrten von der Polizei gesperrt sind und
so ein paar Polizeiwagen vor, der Panzer und ein paar Polizeiwagen da hinten
und der auf der leeren Autobahn aus Berlin raus eskortiert wurde.
Und dann dachte ich, was ist jetzt der Plan? der war nicht so ganz gut auf so
einer der ersten Autobahnraststätten hinter Berlin haben sie gesagt,
hier parken der Rest geht uns nichts an, tschüss und waren weg.
Oh ok eben noch die Autobahn gesperrt und jetzt steht der Panzer in Brandenburg okay, alles klar.
Problem gelöst und wo ich auch dachte, ich bin mir nicht sicher aber darf die
Polizei Berlin in Brandenburg operieren und da einen Panzer abstellen Wir haben den ja abgestellt.
Die Polizei hatte die Verantwortung, weil sie die Anweisung zum Bewegen gegeben hat.
Meine Kernfrage ist natürlich, warum hat sich das Bezirksamt Mitte da so gegen gewehrt?
Ich habe null Ahnung, weil ich wirklich null Kontakt zu irgendwem jemals da gekriegt habe.
Meine erste Idee war ja, ich weiß, das ist kompliziert, lass uns an den Tisch
setzen und lass mal sprechen, was geht oder nicht.
Und einfach mal gucken. Und was genau habt ihr für Sorge? Sagt ihr nicht da oder nicht das Ding?
Oder was weiß ich, kann man ja eine Menge falsch sagen. Ich meine,
du hast ja selber große Kunstinstallationen gemacht.
Ich denke, da wird es auch irgendwelche Gespräche gegeben haben,
das geht, keine Pornos oder was weiß ich, was es so an Auflagen gab.
Man setzt sich hin, man bespricht, man guckt, was geht und was nicht geht.
Ist ja normal. Aber die wollten von Anfang an nicht ein Wort mit uns wechseln.
Und deswegen, vielleicht hätte man es ja lösen können oder irgendwas, aber die wollten nicht.
Und dann nur eine ganz interessante Sache, wie es anders laufen kann.
Als klar war, der Panzer muss danach, also nachdem die Aktion gelaufen ist, irgendwie weg.
War noch nicht klar, wo er hinkommt genau. Es gab verschiedene Ideen,
aber wir mussten planen.
Dann habe ich gedacht, ich habe ja diesen Bunker mit dem Museum,
können wir den nicht davor stellen?
Also geht das oder nicht? Ich weiß nicht, ob es da Auflagen gibt, was weiß ich was.
Das hätte es gegeben da, ne?
Dass der da steht oder gibt es direkt, was weiß ich, dass es heißt,
da ist aber ein U-Bahn-Tunnel drunter, es geht nicht oder irgendwie einfach so.
Ich habe verschiedene Ideen, das ist nicht mal meine erste Wahl,
nur ich muss irgendwie überlegen.
Und dann rief mich ziemlich schnell, ich glaube nach einem Tag,
der zuständige, ich glaube Bezirksstadtrat heißt das an, also sozusagen der
ein oder andere Bürgermeister, die da zuständig für sind,
Und er wirkte, sagen wir mal, mittelbegeistert von der Idee.
Er sagte, nee, das geht nicht, sondern erst mal hat er sich sofort gemeldet und sagte, oh Gott,
er hat da ein paar Dinge, die man da mal besprechen müsste, wenn sowas ist und
er hat da doch die ein oder anderen Bedenken und hat gesagt,
wie konkret ist das denn? Also das ist noch gar nicht konkret.
Und er sagte, oh Gott, oh Gott. Er sagte, hey, wenn es wirklich akut ist,
also wenn du wirklich sagst, die anderen Möglichkeiten scheinen aus,
aber es ist so, ruf mich direkt an, hier ist meine Nummer und dann lass uns
irgendwie drüber sprechen,
weil, also man merkt ja, er ist nicht begeistert von der Idee,
aber es ist sein Job, er ist Bezirksstadtrat, er muss sich irgendwie drum kümmern.
Also er wird schon andere schwierige.
Hat er gesagt, warum er nicht begeistert ist von der Idee?
Er sagte einfach grundsätzlich, er hat Sorge, dass das ein Rattenschwanz mit
Problemen mit sich bringen kann. Wo ich denke, ja, das verstehe ich.
Ich kann mir vorstellen, dass die meisten, gerade Politiker,
keinen Bock haben, dazwischen zu stehen und so ein Ding irgendwie sozusagen
politisch zu verantworten.
Nur ich meine, der hat gesagt, okay, aber wenn es soweit ist,
lass uns telefonieren und dann lass uns gucken, was geht.
Ich dachte, das ist doch mal eine Sache, mit der man arbeiten kann.
Ein paar Tage später hat sich geklärt, dass der in ein Museum in den Niederlanden
kommt. Da habe ich denen auch nochmal eine Mail geschickt. Ich habe gesagt, hey, könnt aufatmen.
Alles gut.
Nur ich dachte, das war eine völlig andere Reaktion. Und dass jemand von Anfang
an sagt, bin ich nicht der größte Fan von, denke ich, ist doch gut.
Dann weiß ich, woran ich bin.
Dann können wir doch sprechen. Also wenn es so weit gekommen wäre.
Bezirksamiter hat auf jeden Fall sich nicht besonders, wie soll ich sagen,
vorbildlich verhalten. Das kann man glaube ich so festhalten.
Ich war ja auch vor Ort.
Hab.
Mir den Panzer angeschaut, der war auch schön kaputt.
Diese russischen Panzer, die wirken dann...
Gut, ich wusste vielleicht in etwa, was mich erwartet, aber man ist,
glaube ich, ein bisschen überrascht, wie klein die doch eigentlich sind.
Das ist ja so eine Eigenschaft der russischen Panzer.
Deswegen wollte ich den auf dem Boden eigentlich haben, weil dann guckt man
rüber, wenn man daneben steht. Und das ist immer, wo die Leute sagen, der ist aber niedrig.
Ja, das ist so ein Kriegs-Coupé. Und es gab trotz der wenigen Tage,
die er dann letzten Endes da stand, was war das.
Zwei oder drei Tage.
War dann doch sehr viel Zulauf, aber auch wirklich von jeder Art Volk.
Also Leute, die das mit Interesse mit oder ohne Anteilnahme zur Kenntnis genommen
haben, aber dann halt auch so völlig Verstrahlte, die da irgendwie rumdemonstriert haben.
Es war sozusagen normale Touris, die haben das einfach wahrgenommen wie alles
in Berlin. Ah, Brandenburger Tor, ein kaputter Panzer, ein Starbucks.
Das war so einer von vielen Fotopunkten.
Dann eben die, die es sehen wollten, die es positiv sahen meist und dann eben
so, aber man muss wirklich sagen, unglaublich wenig so pro-russische Leute,
die auch eigentlich dadurch auffielen, dass sie nur genervt und waren und aggressiv waren.
Also ich habe nicht einen gefunden, der gesagt hat, habe ich ein Problem mit,
lass mal darüber sprechen oder so, sondern es gab so ruhige Leute dafür und
aggressive dagegen irgendwie.
Das fand ich auch so strange, wie sich das da so gezeigt hat.
Polizei war auch mäßig begeistert. Die haben etliche Schlägereien da irgendwie
versorgen und aufnehmen müssen und so.
Durchgehend von der prorussischen Seite angezettelt und irgendwie zwei Leute
sind beim Versuch, eine Russlandfrage auf dem Panzer anzubringen.
Gibt es verschiedene Darstellungen. Wir wollen glauben, dass sie abgerutscht sind.
Sie haben gesagt, sie seien runtergetreten worden. Die Zeugen sagen,
sie sind abgerutscht. Auf jeden Fall lagen sie dann neben dem Panzer mit ihrer Russlandflagge.
Und die Polizei hat gesagt, sie haben es nicht gesehen. Und sie haben auch gesagt, keinen Bock mehr.
Also wo ich auch denke, das tut mir auch echt leid für die, weil es ist wie
immer, die können da nichts für, aber es ist halt ihr Job. Aber das wurde zum
Ende hin zum Teil ein bisschen nerviger.
Okay. Okay, ja trotzdem interessante Aktionen, also man muss ja dazu sagen,
das gab es dann auch nicht nur in Prag und Warschau,
sondern es gab da so einige Wanderpokale mit solchen russischen Panzern in Europa
und ausgerechnet in Berlin hat man sich dann halt so bockig angestellt,
das war schon wirklich ein bisschen beunruhigend.
Hast du denn dieses Geld in irgendeiner Form jetzt, was du da ausgegeben hast,
wieder hereinbekommen können?
Oder habt ihr da jetzt wirklich 100.000 Euro in diese drei Tage Pazza investiert?
Wir haben Crowdfunding gemacht, weil wir dachten, das ist so ein Selbstläufer.
Das bezahlt sich quasi sofort.
Wir sind nicht mal 20.000 bei rumgekommen. Okay.
Also ein Fünftel.
Ja und der Rest passiert. Dafür war es eine Menge Spaß.
Ich sehe schon.
Du hast eine Freude da dran. Und wie.
Gut, Enno, ich denke, an der Stelle machen wir jetzt hier erstmal einen Punkt.
Vielen Dank für die Ausführung.
Gerne.
Und ich denke, wir werden dann auch hier nochmal das eigentliche Kriegsgeschehen
mit Pavel nochmal aufarbeiten. Da ist, wie man es sieht, entweder gar nichts
oder ganz viel passiert.
Das werden wir dann nochmal anschauen.
Aber die Perspektive hat mich jetzt mal interessiert. Also vielen Dank und vielen
Dank fürs Zuhören bei UKW.
Das war es erstmal von mir und wir sprechen uns dann in die Tage wieder.
Ich sage Tschüss und bis bald.